guten tag
mehr fortschritt wagen bündnis für
freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit
koalitionsvertrag
2021 bis 2025 zwischen der
sozialdemokratischen partei deutschlands
spd
bündnis 90 die grünen und den freien
demokraten fdp
erstens präambel
das ergebnis der bundestagswahl
verstehen unsere drei parteien als
auftrag eine gemeinsame
regierungskoalition zu bilden wir haben
unterschiedliche traditionen und
perspektiven doch uns einen die
bereitschaft gemeinsam verantwortung für
die zukunft deutschlands zu übernehmen
das ziel die notwendige modernisierung
voranzutreiben
das bewusstsein dass dieser fortschritt
auch mit einem sicherheitsversprechen
einhergehen muss und die zuversicht dass
dies gemeinsam gelingen kann wir
verpflichten uns dem wohle aller
bürgerinnen und bürger zu dienen
was das land herausfordert
wir übernehmen verantwortung in einer
zeit in der die korona pandemie das land
weiter stark belastet sie bedeutet für
viele großes leid geht einher mit
existenziellen sorgen und verlangt allen
erhebliche einschränkungen ab die
pandemie zu besiegen ist in diesen tagen
unsere vordringlichste aufgabe der wir
uns mit voller kraft widmen die
notwendigen schutzmaßnahmen
umzusetzen und einen umfassenden
impfschutz voranzutreiben ist eine
gesamtstaatliche und
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe die welt
ist am beginn eines jahrzehnts im
umbruch deshalb können wir nicht im
stillstand verharren die klimakrise
gefährdet unsere lebensgrundlagen und
bedroht freiheit wohlstand und
sicherheit
deutschland und europa müssen angesichts
eines verschärften globalen wettbewerbs
ihre ökonomische stärke neu begründen im
internationalen system wettstreit gilt
es unsere werte entschlossen mit
demokratischen partnern zu verteidigen
zugleich verändert die digitalisierung
die art und weise wie wir wirtschaften
arbeiten und miteinander kommunizieren
unsere gesellschaft wird älter und
diverser auch gilt es gesellschaftliche
spannungen in zeiten des schnellen
wandels zu reduzieren und das vertrauen
in unsere demokratie zu stärken
diese herausforderungen sind immens
miteinander verwoben und in ihrer
gleichzeitigkeit anspruchsvoll sie
werden das land und die gesellschaft
über lange zeit prägen doch wenn wir
diese umbrüche gestalten liegen auch
große chancen darin aufgabe dieser
koalition ist es die dafür nötigen
neuerungen politisch anzuschieben und
orientierung zu geben damit wollen wir
eine neue dynamik auslösen die in die
gesamte gesellschaft hineinwirkt
was wir voranbringen wollen
deutschland wird nur auf der höhe der
zeit agieren können wenn wir den staat
selbst modernisieren wir wollen
staatliches handeln schneller und
effektiver machen und besser auf
künftige krisen vorbereiten wir bringen
eine umfassende digitalisierung der
verwaltung voran es geht darum das leben
für die bürgerinnen und bürger leichter
zu machen wir werden die öffentliche
infrastruktur
öffentliche räume und netze
modernisieren und dafür planung
genehmigung und umsetzung deutlich
beschleunigen auch die wirtschaft soll
in der verwaltung einen verbündeten
haben mehr als 30 jahre nach der
deutschen einheit bleibt es unsere
aufgabe die innere einheit sozial und
wirtschaftlich zu vollenden die
lebensverhältnisse in unseren regionen
in städten und dem ländlichen raum sind
nicht gleich aber sie sollten
gleichwertig seien zu guten
lebensbedingungen gehören bezahlbares
wohnen
schnelles internet eine erreichbare
gesundheitsversorgung und
alltagstaugliche nachhaltige
mobilitätsangebote
die klimaschutzziele von paris zu
erreichen hat für uns oberste priorität
klimaschutz sichert freiheit
gerechtigkeit und nachhaltigen wohlstand
es gilt die soziale marktwirtschaft als
eine sozial-ökologische
eine sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
neu zu begründen wir schaffen ein
regelwerk das den weg frei macht für
innovationen und maßnahmen um
deutschland auf den 1,5 grad pfad zu
bringen
wir bringen neues tempo in die
energiewende in dem wir würden für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien aus dem
weg räumen schritt für schritt beenden
wir dass fossile zeitalter auch indem
wir den kohleausstieg idealerweise auf
2.030 vorziehen und die technologie des
verbrennungsmotors hinter uns lassen
unseren wohlstand in der globalisierung
zu sichern ist nur möglich wenn wir
wirtschaftlich und technologisch weiter
in der spitzenliga spielen und die
innovationskräfte unsere wirtschaft
entfalten
grundlage dafür sind faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen
dazu gehört auch eine faire besteuerung
national und international sowie die
konsequente bekämpfung von
steuerhinterziehung
in die modernisierung des landes muss
umfassend investiert werden privat wie
öffentlich die öffentlichen
investitionen insbesondere in
klimaschutz
digitalisierung bildung und forschung
werden wir im rahmen der bestehenden
schuldenregel des grundgesetzes
gewährleisten anreize für private
investitionen setzen und raum für
unternehmerisches wagnis schaffen umso
wachstum zu generieren
die nötigen fachkräfte wollen wir durch
bessere bildungschancen
bessere bildungschancen gezielte
weiterbildung die erhöhung der
erwerbsbeteiligung sowie durch eine
modernisierung des einwanderungsrechts
gewinnen
jede und jeder soll das eigene leben
frei und selbstbestimmt gestalten können
aber die chancen sind nicht für alle
gleich verteilt deshalb müssen die
grundlagen für soziale aufstiegschancen
in kita und schule gelegt werden wir
konzentrieren uns auf die bereiche in
denen unterstützung besonders gebraucht
wird und wollen enger mit den ländern
zusammenarbeiten
wir wollen familien stärken und mehr
kinder aus der armut holen daher führen
dafür führen wir eine
kindergrundsicherung ein kinder haben
eigene rechte die wir im grundgesetz
verankern werden
berufsbiografien sind häufig von brüchen
geprägt gerade in zeiten des wandels
wir wollen sicherheit auch im übergang
geben und dazu ermutigen neues zu wagen
leistung muss anerkannt und arbeit
gerecht bezahlt werden darum werden wir
den mindestlohn auf 12 eur anheben und
uns für entgeltgleichheit von frauen und
männern einsetzen wir halten das
rentenniveau stabil erweitern die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung um eine
teilweise kapitaldeckung und werden das
system der privaten altersvorsorge
grundlegend reformieren wir lösen die
grundsicherung durch ein neues
bürgergeld ab damit die würde des
einzelnen geachtet und gesellschaftliche
teilhabe besser gefördert wird die kraft
unserer republik liegt in der
freiheitlichen vielfalt und im
demokratischen und sozialen zusammenhalt
sicherheit und freiheit bedingen
einander die sicherheitsbehörden und
ihre beschäftigten verdienen respekt und
unterstützung wir wollen ihre strukturen
und zusammenarbeit effizienter machen
wir verteidigen unseren rechtsstaat und
sichern den schutz unserer bürgerinnen
und bürger
unsere maxime ist eine freie
gesellschaft in der die gleichstellung
von frauen und männern verwirklicht ist
sowie unterschiedliche lebensentwürfe
und biographien ihren platz haben uns
verbindet das verständnis von
deutschland als vielfältiger
einwanderungsgesellschaft um der
gesellschaftlichen wirklichkeit rechnung
zu tragen
ermöglichen wir gleichberechtigte
teilhabe und modernisieren die
rechtsnormen vom familienrecht bis hin
zum staatsbürgerschaftsrecht jeglicher
diskriminierung
wirken wir entgegen eine starke
demokratie lebt von den menschen die sie
tragen sie braucht eine vielfältige
kultur und freie medien ehrenamt und
demokratisches engagement stärken den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt sie
verlässlich zu fördern ist unsere
aufgabe die großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit lassen sich nur in
internationaler kooperation und
gemeinsam in einer starken europäischen
union bewältigen wir stehen zur globalen
verantwortung deutschlands als einer
großen industrienationen in der welt der
einsatz für frieden freiheit
menschenrechte demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit und nachhaltigkeit
ist für uns unverzichtbarer teil einer
erfolgreichen und glaubwürdigen
außenpolitik wir bekennen uns zu unserer
human zu unserer homie wir bekennen uns
zu unserer humanitären schutz
verantwortung und wollen die verfahren
zu flucht und migration ordnen wir
handeln dabei im europäischen
selbstverständnis und in abstimmung mit
unseren internationalen partnern
die strategische souveränität der
europäischen union wollen wir erhöhen
indem wir unsere außen- sicherheits-
entwicklungs und handelspolitik werte
basiert und als basis gemeinsamer
europäischer interessen ausrichten
wie wir arbeiten wollen
deutschland ist vielfältig und die
gesellschaft ist freier und reicher an
perspektiven aber auch komplexer und
widersprüchlicher geworden
gemeinsinn solidarität und zusammenhalt
sind neu zu bestimmen das gelingt nicht
indem man über unterschiede hinweg geht
sondern in dem die unterschiedlichen
stimmen in unserem land gleichberechtigt
gehör finden in diesem sinne spiegelt
eine koalition aus unseren drei so
unterschiedlichen parteien auch einen
teil der komplexen gesellschaftlichen
wirklichkeit wider wenn wir es schaffen
gemeinsam die dinge voranzutreiben kann
das ein ermutigendes signal in die
gesellschaft hinein sein dass
zusammenhalt und fortschritt auch bei
unterschiedlichen sichtweisen gelingen
können wir wollen eine kultur des
respekts befördern respekt für andere
meinungen für gegenargumente und streit
für andere lebenswelten und
einstellungen der vorliegende
koalitionsvertrag
zeigt dass wir tragfähige gemeinsame
lösungen gefunden haben er bildet die
arbeitsgrundlage für unsere koalition
zweitens moderner staat digitaler
aufbruch und innovationen
deutschland muss handlungs und
leistungsfähig sein insbesondere in
krisenzeiten
der staat muss vorausschauend für seine
bürgerinnen und bürger arbeiten dazu
wollen wir ihn modernisieren so dass er
chancen ermöglicht und sicherheit gibt
ein staat der die kooperation mit
wirtschaft und zivilgesellschaft sucht
mehr transparenz und teilhabe in seinen
entscheidungen bietet und mit einer
unkomplizierten schnellen und digitalen
verwaltung das leben der menschen
einfacher macht für die vor uns
liegenden aufgaben braucht das tempo
beim infrastrukturausbau die verfahren
entscheidungen und umsetzungen müssen
deutlich schneller werden wir werden
deshalb planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren modernisieren
entbürokratisieren und digitalisiert so
wie die
personalkapazitäten verbessern indem wir
bürgerinnen und bürger früher beteiligen
machen wir die planungen schneller und
effektiver
wir wollen das potenzial der
digitalisierung in staat und
gesellschaft besser nutzen unser ziel
ist die flächendeckende versorgung mit
glasfaser und dem neuesten
mobilfunkstandard wir werden digitale
schlüssel technologien fördern und die
bedingungen für startups am
technologiestandort verbessern
wir haben lust auf neues und werden
technologische digitale soziale und
nachhaltige innovationskraft befördern
durch bessere rahmenbedingungen für
hochschule wissenschaft und forschung
wollen wir den wissen schon wollen wir
den wissenschaftsstandort kreativer und
wettbewerbsfähiger machen
wissenschafts und forschungsfreiheit
sind der schlüssel für kreative ideen
die dazu beitragen die großen
herausforderungen unserer zeit zu
bewältigen
moderner staat und demokratie
wir wollen einen grundlegenden wandel
hin zu einem ermöglichen den lernenden
und digitalen start der vorausschauend
für die bürgerinnen und bürger arbeitet
es geht darum das leben einfacher zu
machen staatliches handeln soll
schneller und effektiver werden und
wirtschaftlicher wie gesellschaftliche
innovationsprozesse befördern und
einbinden wir wollen eine neue kultur
der zusammenarbeit etablieren die auch
aus der kraft der zivilgesellschaft
heraus gespeist wird
verwaltungsmodernisierung
die verwaltung soll agiler und digitaler
werden sie muss auf interdisziplinäre
und kreative problemlösungen setzen wir
werden sie konsequent aus der nutzungs
perspektive heraus wir werden sie
konsequent aus der nutzungs perspektive
heraus denken wir wollen das silodenken
überwinden und werden feste ressort und
behörden übergreifende agile
projektteams und innovations- einheiten
mit konkreten kompetenzen ausstatten wir
werden proaktives verwaltungshandeln
durch antrags lose und automatisierte
verfahren gesetzlich verankern
von der leitung der ministerien
und den führungskräften im öffentlichen
dienst erwarten wir dass sie eine
moderne führungs und verwaltungskultur
vorantreiben und für digitale lösungen
sorgen eigeninitiative und mut der
beschäftigen müssen wertgeschätzt und
belohnt werden die modernisierung des
staates gelingt nur mit einem starken
öffentlichen dienst diesen werden wir
auf diesen werden wir attraktiver
gestalten der staat muss bei vielfalt
gleichstellung und flexiblen sowie
digitalen arbeitsbedingungen vorbild
sein wir fördern und vereinfachen den
personalaustausch und die rotation
zwischen verschiedenen behörden zwischen
bund und ländern sowie zwischen
verwaltung und privatwirtschaft die
einstellungsvoraussetzungen
flexibilisieren wir in richtung
praktischer berufserfahrung und stärken
das instrument des alters geldes die
digitalisierung wird zu einem
allgemeinen und behörden übergreifenden
kernbestandteil der ausbildung um die
integrität des öffentlichen dienstes
sicherzustellen werden wir dafür sorgen
dass verfassungsfeinde schneller als
bisher aus dem dienst entfernt werden
können
lebendige demokratie
demokratie lebt vom vertrauen in alle
staatlichen institutionen und
verfassungsorgane wir werden daher das
parlament als ort der debatte und der
gesetzgebung stärken wir wollen die
qualität der gesetzgebung verbessern
dazu werden wir neue vorhaben frühzeitig
und ressort übergreifend auch in neuen
formaten diskutieren wir werden dabei
die praxis und betroffene kreise aus der
gesellschaft und vertreterinnen und
vertreter des parlaments besser
einbinden sowie die erfahrungen und
erfolg und erfordernisse von ländern und
kommunen bei der konkreten gesetzes
ausführung berücksichtigen im vorfeld
des gesetzgebungsverfahrens soll die
möglichkeit der digitalen ausführung
geprüft werden digital check wir werden
ein zentrum für logistik
errichten
vielleicht soll es logistik heißen ich
weiß es nicht ob das ein druckfehler ist
ich lese mal beide sätze vor wir werden
ein zentrum für logistik errichten oder
wir werden ein zentrum für logistik
errichten
wir werden ein digitales gesetzgebungs
portal schaffen über dass einsehbar ist
in welcher phase sich vorhaben befinden
dort werden wir öffentliche
kommentierung möglichkeiten erproben
gesetzentwürfen der bundesregierung wird
künftig eine synopse beigefügt die die
aktuelle rechtslage den geplanten
änderungen gegenüber stellt wir wollen
gesetze
verständlicher machen die
barrierefreiheit in den angeboten von
bundestag und bundesregierung werden wir
ausbauen wir wollen die
entscheidungsfindung verbessern indem
wir neue formen des bürgerdialogs wie
etwa bürger räte nutzen ohne das prinzip
der repräsentation aufzugeben wir werden
bürger räte zu konkreten fragestellungen
durch den bundestag einsetzen und
organisieren dabei werden wir auf
gleichberechtigte teilhabe achten eine
befassung des bundestages mit den
ergebnissen wird sichergestellt dass
petitionsverfahren werden wir insgesamt
stärken und digitalisieren und die
möglichkeit schaffen öffentliche
petitionen in ausschüssen und im plenum
zu beraten
transparenz
wir wollen durch mehr transparenz unsere
demokratie stärken uns leiten die
prinzipien offenen regierungshandelns
transparenz partizipation und
zusammenarbeit wir werden das
lobbyregister gesetz nach scharfen
kontakte zu ministerien ab referenten
ebene einbeziehen und den kreis der
eintragungspflicht igen
interessenvertretungen grundrechts
schonend und differenziert erweitern für
gesetzentwürfe der bundesregierung und
aus dem bundestag werden wir einflüsse
dritter im rahmen der vorbereitung von
gesetzesvorhaben und bei der erstellung
von gesetzentwürfen
umfassend offenlegen so genannter
fußabdruck
die regelung findet ihre grenzen in der
freiheit des mann wir wollen die
nationalen aktionspläne im rahmen der
open government partnership ppp
deutschlands umsätze und
weiterentwickeln wir werden den
straftatbestand der
abgeordnetenbestechung
und bestechlichkeit wirksamer
ausgestaltet
parteien sponsoring werden wir ab einer
bagatellgrenze
veröffentlichungspflichtig machen die
pflicht zur sofortigen veröffentlichung
von zuwendungen an parteien wird auf
35.000 euro herabgesetzt spenden und
mitgliedsbeiträge die in der summe 7500
euro pro jahr überschreiten werden im
rechenschaftsbericht
veröffentlichungspflichtig wir schützen
die integrität des politischen
wettbewerbs vor einer beeinträchtigung
durch verdeckte wahlkampffinanzierung
mittels sogenannter parallel aktionen
die bundestagsverwaltung wird für ihre
aufsichts und kontrollfunktion in den
bereichen transparenz und
parteienfinanzierung personell und
finanziell besser ausgestattet wir
wollen das parteiengesetz auf den stand
der zeit bringen und dabei insbesondere
den parteien mehr digitale
beschlussfassungen und im rahmen der
verfassungsrechtlichen grenzen digitale
wahlen ermöglichen dies soll unter
einbeziehung möglichst aller
demokratischen fraktionen geschehen
politische bildung und demokratie
förderung sind mehr gefördert gefordert
denn je denn auch in deutschland steht
die polo realistische freiheitliche
demokratie unter druck akteurinnen und
akteure der nachhaltigen demokratie
förderung die auf basis von respekt
toleranz würde und menschenrechten
arbeiten werden auch in zukunft mit
öffentlichen mitteln gefördert
die arbeit und finanzierung der
politischen stiftungen wollen wir
rechtlich besser absichern dies soll aus
der mitte des parlaments geschehen unter
einbeziehung möglichst aller
demokratischen fraktionen die
informationsfreiheitsgesetze werden wir
zu einem bundes transparenzgesetz
weiterentwickeln
föderalismus
der föderalismus ist eine grundsäulen
der bundesrepublik um die
leistungsfähigkeit zu erhöhen braucht es
klarheit bei den aufgaben und der
finanzierung wir streben eine engere
zielgenauere und verbindliche
kooperation zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen an dazu werden wir gemeinsam
mit kommunen und ländern einen
föderalismus dialog zur transparenten
und effizienten verteilung der aufgaben
insbesondere zu den themen katastrophen
und bevölkerungsschutz bildung und
innere sicherheit sowie zur nutzung der
möglichkeiten der digitalisierung führen
wir stehen zum bonn-berlin-gesetz
hierzu wird der bund mit der region bonn
sowie den ländern nordrhein westfalen
und rheinland pfalz eine vertragliche
zusatzvereinbarung abschließen
wahlrecht wir werden innerhalb des
ersten jahres das wahlrecht überarbeiten
um nachhaltig das anwachsen des
bundestages zu verhindern der bundestag
muss effektiv in richtung der
gesetzlichen regelung größe verkleinert
werden eine verzerrung der
sitzverteilung durch unausgeglichene
überhangmandate lehnen wir ab
wir werden die kommission zur reform des
bundes wahlrechts und zur modernisierung
der parlamentsarbeit erneut einsetzen
die kommission wird sich mit dem ziel
einer paritätischen repräsentanz von
frauen und männern im parlament befassen
und die rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen
erörtern die kommission wird zudem
vorschläge zur bündelung von
wahlterminen zur verlängerung der
legislaturperiode auf fünf jahre sowie
zur begrenzung der amtszeit des
bundeskanzlers der bundeskanzlerin
prüfen wir werden das aktive zwar wir
werden das aktive wahlalter für die
wahlen zum europäischen parlament auf 16
jahre senken wir wollen das grundgesetz
ändern um das aktive wahlalter für die
wahl zum deutschen bundestag auf 16
jahre zu senken
wir wollen die ausübung des wahlrechts
für im ausland lebende deutsche
erleichtern
planungs und genehmigungsbeschluss
um deutschland zügig zu modernisieren
sind schnelle verwaltungs planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren zentrale
voraussetzungen daher sollen im ersten
jahr der regierung alle notwendigen
entscheidungen getroffen und
durchgesetzt werden um private wie
staatliche investitionen schnell
effizient und zielsicher umsetzen zu
können
unser ziel ist es die verfahrensdauer
mindestens zu halbieren dafür müssen
staat und gesellschaft sowie bund länder
und kommunen an einem strang ziehen wir
wollen eine auf rechtssicherheit und
gegenseitigem vertrauen fußen de
planungskultur in deutschland
verwirklichen alle staatlichen stellen
sollen verwaltungsverfahren so
vereinfachen und verbessern das
gerichtliche auseinandersetzungen
möglichst vermieden werden wir werden
mehr möglichkeiten im rahmen des
verfassungs- und unionsrechts ausnutzen
wir werden die personellen und
technischen kapazitäten bei behörden und
gerichten erhöhen für eine personal- und
weiterbildungsoffensive
sowie die digitalisierung auf allen
ebenen streben wir einen verlässlichen
und nachhaltigen pakt für planungs
genehmigungs und umsetzungs
beschleunigung mit den ländern an die
inhouse beratungskapazitäten der
öffentlichen hand werden zu
beschleunigungs agenturen ausgebaut auf
die auch länder und kommunen einfach
zugreifen können die
einsatzmöglichkeiten für private
projektmanagerinnen und projektmanager
werden ausgedehnt für angelegenheiten
des planungsrechts schaffen wir die
voraussetzungen für zusätzliche senate
am bundesverwaltungsgericht die
bundesregierung verstärkt ihre kompetenz
zur unterstützung dialogischer
bürgerbeteiligungsverfahren
die digitalisierung von planungs und
genehmigungsprozesse werden wir
priorisiert um priorisiert umsetzen wir
werden behörden mit notwendiger technik
ausstatten die schnittstellen zwischen
bund und ländern standardisieren und das
digitale portal für umwelt daten zu
einem öffentlich nutzbaren zentralen
archiv für kartierungs und artendaten
ausbauen
bereits erhobene daten sind
gegebenenfalls durch plausibilisiert
führungen möglichst lange nutzbar zu
machen
planungsprozesse werden mit gebäude
datenmodellierung building information
modeling
effizienter kostengünstiger und
transparenter gestaltet die digitalen
möglichkeiten des planungs
sicherstellung des gesetzes werden wir
nahtlos fortsetzen und insbesondere im
hinblick auf die bürgerbeteiligung
weiterentwickeln
um verwaltungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
werden wir eine frühstmögliche und
intensiver öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung
einführen diese wird mit einer mit
mitwirkungspflicht für die anerkannten
naturschutzverbände und für die
betroffene öffentlichkeit kombiniert wir
wollen eine wirksame und unions
rechtlich zulässige form der materiellen
präzision einführen
wir werden frühzeitige verfahrens
konferenzen in den behörden einführen
wir werden möglichst frühe stichtage für
die anzuwendende sach und rechtslage
vorsehen wir wollen klarstellen dass
wiederholte auslegungs anwendungs und
erwiderung schleifen vermieden werden
können indem bei planänderungen nach
bürgerbeteiligung nur noch neu
betroffene zu beteiligen und
einwendungen nur mehr gegen
planänderungen zulässig sind wir werden
verwaltungsinterne fristen und
genehmigungs fiktionen bei beteiligung
weiterer behörden ausweiten
bei besonders prioritären vorhaben soll
der bund künftig nach dem vorbild des
bundesimmissionsschutzgesetzes
kurze fristen zum erlass des
planfeststellungsbeschlusses
vorsehen wir wollen große und besonders
bedeutsame
infrastrukturmaßnahmen auch im wege zu
lässiger und union unions
rechtskonformer legal planung
beschleunigt auf den weg bringen und mit
hoher politischer priorität umsetzen
unter solchen
infrastrukturmaßnahmen verstehen wir
systemrelevante bahnstrecken
stromtrassen und ingenieurs bauwerke zum
beispiel kritische brücken
für die ausgestaltung werden wir uns eng
mit der europäischen kommission
abstimmen die erforderliche
umweltprüfung durchführen und durch den
zugang zu bundesverwaltungsgericht den
rechtsschutz und die effektivität des
umweltrechts sicherstellen für geeignete
fälle kommt auch eine übernahme des
raumordnungsverfahrens durch den bund in
betracht beginnen werden wir mit
schienenprojekten aus dem deutschland
takt dem ausbau neubau der bahnstrecken
hannover-berlin
korridor mittelrhein hanau hanau
würzburg fulda erfurt münchen
kiefersfelden grenze dpa karlsruhe basel
optimiertes alpha e-plus ostkorridor süd
nürnberg
reichenbach grenze
dtz
die knoten hamburg frankfurt köln
mannheim und münchen sowie mit für die
energiewende zentralen hochspannungs
gleichstrom übertragungsleitungen süd
link südost link und ultra net weitere
vorhaben werden hinzukommen
wir werden eine engere verzahnung
zwischen raumordnungs und
planfeststellungsverfahren
ermöglichen um doppelprüfungen zu
vermeiden wir wollen das instrument der
plangenehmigung
insbesondere bei unterhaltungs
sanierungs erneuerungs ersatz und
ergänzungsmethoden
räumlichen zusammenhang mit
existierenden infrastrukturen innerhalb
des europäischen rechtsrahmens stärker
nutzbar machen wir streben an
sonderregeln für einzelne gebiete der
fachplanung in das allgemeine
verwaltungsverfahrens recht zu
überführen soweit dies möglich und
sinnvoll ist wir wollen den plan erhalt
stärken indem wir die plan erhaltungs
normen und zielabweichungsverfahren
ausweiten
verwaltungsgerichtsverfahren werden wir
beschleunigen durch einen frühen ersten
termin sowie durch ein effizienteres
einstweiligen rechtsschutzverfahren in
dem
fehler heilungen maßgeblich
berücksichtigt werden und auf die
reversible i tät von maßnahmen
abgestellt wird klägerinnen und kläger
deren rechtsbehelfe zur fehlerbehebung
beitragen werden die verfahren ohne
nachteil beenden können wir wollen die
rechtssicherheit im artenschutzrecht
durch bundeseinheitliche gesetzliche
standard
insbesondere signifikanz schwellen
erhöhen ohne das schutzniveau insgesamt
abzusenken
für unsere gemeinsame mission die
planung von
infrastruktur projekten insbesondere den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
drastisch zu beschleunigen wollen wir
das verhältnis von klimaschutz und
artenschutz klären zur erreichung der
klimaziele liegt die errichtung von
anlagen zur erzeugung oder zum transport
von strom aus erneuerbaren energien
sowie der ausbau elektrifizierter
bahntrassen im öffentlichen interesse
und dient der öffentlichen sicherheit
dies werden wir gesetzlich festschreiben
und für solche projekte unter gewissen
voraussetzungen eine regel vermutung für
das vorliegen der ausnahme
voraussetzungen des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes
schaffen wir werden uns für eine
stärkere ausrichtung auf den population
schutz eine klärung des verhältnisses
von arten und klimaschutz sowie mehr
standardisierung und rechtssicherheit
auch im unionsrecht einzel einsetzen
ähnliche prüfungen im rahmen eines
genehmigungsverfahrens wollen wir
womöglich in einer integrierten prüfung
zusammenführen ohne das schutzniveau
abzusenken wir wollen gegebenenfalls
durch öffnungsklauseln dafür sorgen dass
das zusammenwirken zwischen gemeinden
und ländern bei der sicherstellung der
versorgung mit erneuerbaren energien
gelingt diese maßnahmen werden begleitet
durch projektbezogene und gesamt
bilanzierende ausgleichsmaßnahmen die
einen hohen umwelt- und naturschutz
sicherstellen zu schnellen und
qualitativ hochwertigen umsetzung
unserer beschleunigungs vorhaben werden
wir eine ressortübergreifende
steuerungsgruppe unter einbeziehung der
länder einrichten
digitale innovationen und digitale
infrastruktur
deutschland braucht einen umfassenden
digitalen aufbruch
wir wollen das potenzial der
digitalisierung für die
entfaltungsmöglichkeiten der menschen
für wohlstand freiheit soziale teilhabe
und nachhaltigkeit nutzen dafür werden
wir uns ambitionierte und überprüfbare
ziele setzen sowie realistische und
schnell spürbare maßnahmen ergreifen
kompetenzen in der bundesregierung
werden neu geordnet und gebündelt ein
zentrales zusätzliches digital budget
eingeführt und gesetze einem
digitalisierungs scheck unterzogen
die verwaltung wird digitaler und
konsequent bürger orientiert wir fördern
digitale innovationen sowie
unternehmerische und gesellschaftliche
initiative und setzten auf offene
standards und diversität wir stärken die
digitale kompetenz
grundrechte selbstbestimmung und den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt wir
sorgen für sicherheit und respekt auch
in zeiten des wandels wir machen aus
technologischen auch gesellschaftlichen
fortschritt dabei ist uns bewusst
ein digitaler aufbruch der unsere werte
die digitale souveränität und einen
starken technologie standort sichert
gelingt nur in einem fortschrittlichen
europäischen rahmen
digitaler start und digitale verwaltung
die menschen erwarten vom staat einfach
handhabbare und zeitgemäße digitale
leistungen
nutzerorientiert
medienbruchfrei und flächendeckend
lösungen durch automation wie die
automatisierte auszahlung der
kindergrundsicherung setzen wir
prioritär um
die weiterentwicklung des online zugangs
gesetzes zg geht mit einer ausreichenden
folgefinanzierung einher mit der eine
klare standardisierung und
vereinheitlichung von it verfahren
nachdem einer für alle prinzip
unterstützt wird im rahmen der
konsolidierung
solide schaffen wir klare
verantwortlichkeiten und führen die it
budgets des bundes zentral zusammen aus
der föderalen kooperation fit co machen
wir eine agile flexibler einheit mit
einem mehrjährigen globalbudget
kommunen müssen von bundesmitteln
profitieren
und im rahmen des prinzips entwickelte
lösungen übernehmen können
digitalisierungs hemmnisse schriftform
und anderes bauen wir mittels
generalklausel ab und vereinheitlichen
begriffe zum beispiel einkommen ein
vertrauenswürdiges allgemein anwendbares
identitätsmanagement sowie die
verfassungsfeste register modernisierung
haben priorität für öffentliche projekte
schreiben wir offene standards fest
entwicklungsaufträge werden wir in der
regel werden in der regel als open
source beauftragt die entsprechende
software wird grundsätzlich öffentlich
gemacht
auf basis einer multi cloud strategie
und offener schnittstellen sowie
strenger sicherheits und transparenz
vorgaben bauen wir eine cloud der
öffentlichen verwaltung auf
digitale infrastruktur
unser ziel ist die flächendeckende
versorgung mit glasfaser fiber to the
home ftth
und dem neuesten mobilfunkstandard der
eigenwirtschaftliche ausbau hat vorrang
insbesondere dort wo der nachholbedarf
am größten ist allen voran weiße flecken
investieren wir unter wahrung des
investitionsschutzes
ermöglichen der open access to zu fairen
bedingungen wo nötig regulatorisch wir
sorgen für tempo beim
infrastrukturausbau durch schlanke
digitale antrags und
genehmigungsverfahren
normierung alternativer verleger
techniken und aufbau eines bundesweiten
gigabit book grundbuchs
gigabyte
wir stärken den verbraucherschutz bei
zugesicherten bandbreiten
nötigenfalls durch pauschale durch
nötigenfalls durch pauschalierte
schadensersatzansprüche auf basis von
potenzialanalysen treiben wie die
glasfaserausbau förderung auch ohne
aufgreift schwelle voran öffentlicher
vollfinanzierung hat das betreibermodell
vorrang wir rücken die förderung ganzer
cluster in den fokus und machen
markterkundungsverfahren schneller und
verbindlicher wir stoßen als ergänzung
zu ftth und inhouse glasfaserverkabelung
wo nötig eine förderung mittels voucher
an wir bündeln kompetenzen und aufgaben
für festnetz und mobilfunk wir richten
die frequenzvergabe auf vorgaben für
flächenversorgung aus auch negative
auktionen sollen zum einsatz kommen wir
beschleunigen die maßnahmen für besseren
mobilfunk und wlan empfang bei der bahn
wir prüfen wege hin zu einer besseren
digitalen teilhabe für alle zb durch
barrierefreiheit wir sichern die
netzneutralität
digitale bürgerrechte und sicherheit
wir stärken digitale bürgerrechte und
it-sicherheit sie zu gewährleisten ist
staatliche pflicht wir führen ein recht
auf verschlüsselung ein wirksames
schwachstellenmanagement mit dem ziel
sicherheitslücken zu schließen und die
vorgaben security by design die ford ein
auch der staat muss verpflichtend die
möglichkeit echter verschlüsselter
kommunikation anbieten
[Musik]
hersteller haften für schäden die
fahrlässig durch
sicherheitslücken in ihren produkten
verursacht werden die cyber
sicherheitsstrategie und das it
sicherheits recht werden
weiterentwickelt
darüber hinaus sichern wir die digitale
souveränität unter anderem durch das
recht auf interoperabilität
und portabilität sowie das setzen auf
offene standards open source und
europäische ökosysteme etwa bei 5 g oder
ki wir leiten einen strukturellen umbau
der sicherheitsarchitektur
einstellen das bundesamt für sicherheit
in der informationstechnik bsi
unabhängiger auf und bauen ist als
zentrale stelle im bereich it-sicherheit
aus der verpflichten alle staatlichen
stellen ihnen bekannte sicherheitslücken
beim bsi zu melden und sich regelmäßig
einer externen überprüfung ihrer
it-systeme zu unterziehen das
identifizieren melden und schließen von
sicherheitslücken in einem
verantwortlichen verfahren zb in der it
sicherheitsforschung soll legal
durchführbar sein fett weg den wir als
mittel der cyber abwehr grundsätzlich ab
nicht vertrauenswürdige unternehmen
werden beim ausbau kritischer
infrastrukturen nicht beteiligt
nutzung von daten und daten riecht
die potenziale von daten für alle heben
wir indem wir den aufbau von daten
infrastrukturen unterstützen und
instrumente wie daten treuhänder daten
drehscheiben und daten spenden gemeinsam
mit wirtschaft wissenschaft und
zivilgesellschaft auf den weg bringen
wir streben einen besseren zugang zu
daten an insbesondere um start ups sowie
kmu neue innovative geschäftsmodelle und
soziale innovationen in der
digitalisierung zu ermöglichen ein daten
institut soldaten verfügbarkeit und
standardisierung vorantreiben daten
treuhänder modelle und lizenzen
etablieren für gebietskörperschaften
schaffen wir zu fairen und
wettbewerbskonformen bedingungen zugang
zu daten von unternehmen insofern dies
zur erbringung ihrer aufgaben der
daseinsvorsorge
erforderlich ist
für alle die an der entstehung von daten
mitgewirkt haben stärken wir den
standardisierten und maschinenlesbaren
zugang zu selbst erzeugten daten
mit einem daten gesetz schaffen wir für
diese maßnahmen die notwendigen
rechtlichen grundlagen wir fördern
anonymisierungs techniken schaffen
rechtssicherheit durch standards und
führen die strafbarkeit rechtswidriger
de anonymisierung 1
wir führen einen rechtsanspruch auf open
data ein und verbessern die daten
expertise öffentlicher stellen die
datenschutz grund verordnungen dsgv ist
eine gute internationale standardsetzer
zur besseren durchsetzung und kohärenz
des datenschutzes
verstärken wir die europäische
zusammenarbeit
institutionalisieren die datenschutz
konferenz im bundesdatenschutzgesetz
bdsg und wollen ihr rechtlich womöglich
verbindliche beschlüsse ermöglichen wir
schaffen regelungen zum
beschäftigtendatenschutz zum
beschäftigtendatenschutz um
rechtsklarheit für arbeitgeber sowie
beschäftigte zu erreichen und die
persönlichkeitsrechte effektiv zu
schützen
wir setzen uns für eine schnelle
verabschiedung
einer ambitionierten e privacy
verordnung ein
digitale gesellschaft
wir werden das digitale ehrenamt
sichtbarer machen unterstützen und
rechtlich stärken die zivilgesellschaft
binden wir besser in digital politische
vorhaben ein und unterstützen sie
insbesondere in den bereichen diversität
und civic tag beim digital services act
setzen wir uns für die wahrung der
kommunikationsfreiheit starke
nutzerrechte klare meldeverfahren den
zugang zu daten sehr großer plattformen
für forschungszwecke die überprüfbarkeit
ihrer algorithmischen systeme sowie
klare regelungen gegen desinformationen
1 auf grundlage der europäischen
vorgaben werden wir den rechtsrahmen
unter anderem telemediengesetz tmg und
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz netz.de
grundlegend überarbeiten den aufbau von
plattform räten werden wir voranbringen
allgemeine überwachungspflichten
maßnahmen zum scannen privater
kommunikation und eine identifizierung
pflicht lehnen wir ab anonyme und
pseudonyme online-nutzung werden wir
waren mit einem gesetz gegen digitale
gewalt
werden wir rechtliche hürden für
betroffene wie lücken bei
auskunftsrechte abbauen und umfassende
beratungsangebote aufsetzen wir schaffen
die rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen für
elektronische verfahren zur
anzeigenerstattung und für private
verfahren und ermöglichen richterlich
angeordnete account sperren
wir werden die einrichtung einer
bundeszentrale für digitale bildung
prüfen
digitale schlüssel technologien
wir werden treiber eines staaten
technologiestandorts der auf
europäischen werten basiert talente
anzieht sowie zukunftsfähigkeit und
wohlstand unseres landes sichert
investitionen in künstlichen intelligenz
ki
quantentechnologie
cybersicherheit distribute ledger
technologie dlt robotik und weitere
zukunftstechnologien stärken mehr
messbar und setzen schwerpunkte
wir stärken strategische technologie
filter zum beispiel durch importen
projects of common european interest die
pci
und treiben den angekündigten eu chips
act voran
mit europäischen partnerländern fördern
wir die zusammenarbeit starker
europäischer forschungsstandorte
insbesondere bei kali und ermöglichen
institutionelle freiräume im sinne eines
lernenden technologie fördernden staates
setzen wir digital digitale innovationen
in der verwaltung ein schaffen
notwendige rechtsgrundlagen und
transparenz wir unterstützen den
europäischen act wir setzen auf einen
mehrstufigen
risikobasierten ansatz waren digitale
bürgerrechte
insbesondere die
diskriminierungsfreiheit
definieren haftungsregelung regeln und
vermeiden innovations- hemmende ex ante
regulierung
biometrische erkennung im öffentlichen
raum sowie automatisierte staatliches
scoring systeme durch ki sind
europarechtlich auszuschließen
nachhaltigkeit in der digitalisierung
wir wollen die potenziale der
digitalisierung für mehr nachhaltigkeit
nutzen durch die förderung digitaler
zwillinge zb die arbeit an einem
virtuellen modell eines analogen
produkte helfen wir den verbrauch an
ressourcen zu reduzieren wir werden
rechenzentren in deutschland auf
ökologische nachhaltigkeit und
klimaschutz ausrichten unter anderem
durch nutzung der abwärme neue
rechenzentren sind ab 2027
klimaneutral zu betreiben öffentliche
rechenzentren führen bis 2025 ein umwelt
managementsystem nach
emas eco management and audit scheme 1
für it beschaffungen des bundes werden
zertifizierungen wie zum beispiel der
blaue engel standard ersatzteile und
software updates für it geräte müssen
für die übliche nutzungsdauer
verpflichtend verfügbar sein dies ist
den nutzerinnen und nutzern trend zu
machen
digitale wirtschaft
wir unterstützen einen level playing
field im wettbewerb und setzen uns für
ambitionierte regelungen des digital
markets akt dna ein die nicht hinter
bestehende nationale regeln zurück
fallen dürfen dazu gehören auch
europäisch einheitliche
interoperabilitäts verpflichtungen und
regelungen zur fusionskontrolle das
bundeskartellamt stärken wir im umgang
mit plattformen wir fördern digitale
startups in der spätphase finanzierung
und stärken den venture capital standort
wir wollen den anteil von gründerinnen
im digital sektor erhöhen dafür schaffen
wir ein gründerinnen stipendium und
reservieren ein teil des zukunftsfonds
öffentliche ausschreibungen und
beschaffungsprozesse gestalten wie zum
beispiel für golf und eddie tech start
ups einfacher wir werden die
mitarbeiterkapitalbeteiligung für
startups attraktiver gestalten wir
stärken den games standort deutschland
und verstetigen die förderung der
stärken kmu bei der digitalisierung
durch unkomplizierte förderung und bauen
die unterstützung für it-sicherheit dsgv
konforme datenverarbeitung und den
einsatz digitaler technologien aus
innovation wissenschaft hochschule und
forschung
deutschland ist innovationsland starker
wissenschaft und forschung sind dabei
die garanten für wohlstand
lebensqualität
sozialen zusammenhalt und eine
nachhaltige gesellschaft wir haben lust
auf zukunft und den mut zu veränderungen
sind offen für neues und werden neue
technologische digitale soziale und
nachhaltige innovationskraft entfachen
wir setzen neue impulse für unsere
wissenschafts und forschungslandschaft
unsere universitäten und hochschulen für
angewandte wissenschaften haw werden wir
als herz des wissenschaftssystems
stärken innovation und transfer von der
grundlagenforschung bis in die anwendung
fördern und beschleunigen um unseren
wissenschaftsstandort kreativer
exzellenter und wettbewerbsfähiger zu
machen wollen wir ihn europäisch und
international
weiter vernetzen
geschlechtergerechtigkeit und vielfalt
in all ihren dimensionen sind
qualitätsmerkmale und
wettbewerbsfaktoren im
wissenschaftssystem
wir wollen den anteil der
gesamtstaatlichen ausgaben für forschung
und entwicklung auf 3,5 prozent des bip
bis 2025 erhöhen
zukunftsstrategie forschung
für die lösungen der großen
gesellschaftlichen herausforderungen
benötigen wir eine starke wissenschafts
und forschungspolitik
die entwicklung eines erfolgreichen
impfstoffes gegen saas co2 in
deutschland zeigt wir können unsere
innovationspotenzial heben wenn wir
unsere ressourcen effektiv bündeln und
einsetzen an diesen erfolg wollen wir
anknüpfen indem wir programmlinien
hightech strategie und ressort
forschungen missions- orientiert
weiterentwickeln
ergebnisse werden wir dabei an
internationalen ziel kategorien messen
und die forschungsprojekte übergreifend
vernetzen gewagte forschungsideen finden
in der zukunftsstrategie platz
forschungsbedarf müssen ressort
übergreifend schneller und wirksamer
adressiert werden
zentrale zukunftsfelder sind unter
anderem erstens moderne technologien für
eine wettbewerbsfähige und klimaneutrale
industrie wie stahl und
grundstoffindustrie in deutschland
sicherstellung sauberer energiegewinnung
und versorgung sowie die nachhaltige
mobilität der zukunft
zweitens
klima klimafolgen bio dem biodiversität
nachhaltigkeit erdsystem und
entsprechende anpassungsstrategien sowie
nachhaltiges landwirtschafts und
ernährungssystem
drittens ein vorsorgen des krisenfestes
und modernes gesundheitssystem welches
die chancen biotechnologischer und
medizinischer verfahren nutzt und das
altersabhängige erkrankungen sowie
seltenen oder armutsbedingte krankheiten
bekämpft
viertens technologische souveränität und
die potenziale der digitalisierung zum
beispiel ein künstlicher in die genc und
quantentechnologie für daten basierte
lösungen quer durch alle sektoren
fünftens erforschung von weltraum- und
mähren und schaffung nachhaltiger
nutzungsmöglichkeiten sechs
gesellschaftliche resilienz
geschlechtergerechtigkeit
zusammenhalt demokratie und frieden
forschung an zukunftstechnologien werden
wir stärker als bislang in europäischen
verbündeten zusammenführen wir fördern
gezielt zukunftsweisende groß
forschungsanlagen wir wollen in allen
anwendungsgebieten
biotechnologischer verfahren forschen
und die ergebnisse nutzen
innovationen und transfer
mit einer modernen förderpolitik sorgen
wir für einen erfolgreichen aufbruch in
ein innovations- jahrzehnt mehr
innovationen stärken den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland ebenso
wie die gesamtgesellschaftliche
entwicklung die stärke unserer
innovationskraft liegt in den regionen
denn viele neue ideen entstehen vor ort
wo innovativ an den lösungen der zukunft
gearbeitet wird unser ziel ist die
stärkung von anwendungsorientierter
forschung und transfer zur schaffung und
stärkung regionaler sowie überregionale
innovations- ökosysteme dazu werden wir
die deutsche agentur für transfer und
innovation die ati gründen
um soziale und technologische
innovationen insbesondere an den haw und
kleinen und mittleren universitäten in
zusammenarbeit unter anderem mit
startups kmu sowie sozialen und
öffentlichen organisationen zu fördern
die bestehenden förderprogramme für haw
bauen wir als zentrale erfolgsfaktoren
für die agentur aus perspektivisch
wollen wir unter ihrem dach relevanten
förderprogramme aus den verschiedenen
ressorts bündeln wir werden zeitlich und
räumlich begrenzte experimentier räume
ermöglichen in denen innovative
technologien dienstleistungen oder
geschäftsmodelle unter realen
bedingungen erprobt werden können wir
wollen ausgewählte standorte als
leuchttürme unter die spitzengruppe
internationaler forschung und transfer
regionen mit jeweils einem inhaltlichen
schwerpunkt bringen dazu wollen wir
innovationsregionen nach britischem
vorbild schaffen und dafür
handlungsspielräume des nationalen wie
europäischen rechts nutzen und ausweiten
deutschland hat die chance zum
international führenden biotechnologie
standort zu werden durch den ersten m
rna impfstoff aus mainz hat unser land
weltweite sichtbarkeit erlangt damit ist
eine leitfunktion für die
wissenschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
entwicklung der biotechnologie verbunden
wir wollen die vorhandenen kompetenzen
und entwicklungspotenziale weiter
stärken indem wir mit zusätzlichen
mitteln ein neues forschungszentrum der
helmholtz gemeinschaft für
altersforschung errichten
für einen echten innovationsschub müssen
wir aus gründungen vorantreiben wir
werden hochschulen mittel des bundes zur
schaffung einer gründungs infrastruktur
für technologisches wie soziales
unternehmertum bereitstellen wir wollen
die aus gründungskultur in hochschulen
und außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen in der breite
stärken der dazu benötigte kulturwandel
wird durch science entrepreneurship in
initiativen begleitet wir sind offen für
die etablierung eines german transfer
fand wir fördern plattformen die nicht
verwertete patente dem markt bekannt und
zugänglich machen wir werden die
rechtlichen und finanziellen
rahmenbedingungen für die agentur für
sprung innovation umgehend substanziell
verbessern damit sie freier agieren und
investieren kann wir werden ihre arbeit
in der laufenden wahlperiode evaluieren
forschungsdaten
das ungenutzte potenzial das in
zahlreichen forschungsdaten liegt wollen
wir effektiver für innovative ideen
nutzen den zugang zu forschungsdaten für
öffentliche und private forschung wollen
wir mit einem forschungsdaten gesetz
umfassend verbessern sowie vereinfachen
und führen forschungs klauseln ein open
access wollen wir als gemeinsamen
standard ist bieren wir setzen uns für
ein wissenschafts freundlicheres
urheberrecht ein die nationale
forschungs dateninfrastruktur wollen wir
weiterentwicklung entwickeln und einen
europäischen forschungsdaten raum
vorantreiben daten teilung von
vollständig anonymisiert und nicht
personenbezogenen daten für forschung im
öffentlichen interesse wollen wir
ermöglichen
rahmenbedingungen für hochschule
wissenschaft und forschung
universitäten und hochschulen für
angewandte wissenschaften sind das
rückgrat der deutschen
wissenschaftslandschaft
als solche werden wir sie stärken denn
wo fortschritt entsteht muss auch gelebt
werden wir setzen den weg der
zusammenarbeit zwischen bund und ländern
für ein zukunftsfähiges
wissenschaftssystem ford einer
entkopplung der budgetentwicklung
zwischen hochschulen und
außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen wirken wir
entgegen wir werden den zukunftsvertrag
studium und lehre stärken ab 2022 analog
zu pakt für forschung und innovation
dynamisieren wir werden die stiftung
innovation in der hochschullehre
insbesondere im bereich digitaler lehre
weiter entwickeln mit einem
bundesprogramm digitale hochschule
fördern wir in der breite konzepte für
den ausbau innovativer lehre
qualifizierungsmaßnahmen digitale
infrastrukturen und cyber sicherheit
wir wollen ein bund länder prozess zur
weiterentwicklung des kapazitäts rechts
in gang setzen für die wissenschaftliche
weiterbildung neben der grundständigen
lehre schaffen wir einen rahmen
innerhalb dessen wir die einführung von
micro die gries prüfen die exzellenz
strategie hat sich bewährt und soll als
wettbewerbs raum einmalig mit
zusätzlichen mitteln für weitere cluster
ausgestattet werden wir stärken verbünde
anträge für kooperative oder
interdisziplinäre exzellenzcluster zu
erarbeiten
die im wettbewerb gleichberechtigt
behandelt werden
freie neugier getriebene
grundlagenforschung ist fundament der
staatlichen forschungsförderung die
dünnern die dynamisierung des paktes für
forschung und innovation bfi wollen wir
erhalten wir werden bis zu zwischen eva
nur werden bis zur zwischen evaluation
2025 transparenz über den stand der
zielvereinbarung herstellen und
mechanismen entwickeln um sie künftig
verbindlicher zu machen unser ziel ist
die entscheidung für den strategie
entwicklungsraum wird umgehend umgesetzt
die akademien der wissenschaften werden
analog zum pakt für forschung und
innovation gefördert die perspektivisch
vereinbarte steigerung der programm
pauschalen der deutschen
forschungsgemeinschaft dfg werden wir in
verlässlichen aufwuchs schritten bis zum
ende der vertragslaufzeit des paktes für
forschung und innovation umsätzen
für krisensituationen und prioritäre
handlungsfelder werden wir vereinfachte
und beschleunigte verfahren der
forschungsförderung entwickeln wir
werden bürokratie in forschung und
verwaltung durch shared service
plattformen synergie management und
effizientere berichtspflichten abbauen
in der gesetzesfolgenabschätzung
wenn wir künftig auch
innovationspotenziale konsequent
erfassen
arbeitsbedingungen in der wissenschaft
gute wissenschaft braucht verlässliche
arbeitsbedingungen deswegen wollen wir
das wissenschafts zeit vertrags gesetz
auf basis der evaluation reformieren
dabei wollen wir die planbarkeit und
verbindlichkeit in der post doc phase
deutlich erhöhen und frühzeitiger
perspektiven für alternative karrieren
schaffen wir wollen die
vertragslaufzeiten von promotion stellen
an die gesamte erwartbare
projektlaufzeit knüpfen und darauf
hinwirken dass in der wissenschaft dauer
stellen für dauer- aufgaben geschaffen
werden wir tragen für eine verbesserte
qualitätssicherung der promotion sorge
wir wollen die familien und behinderten
politische komponente für alle
verbindlich machen dass terry truck
programm werden wir verstetigen ausbauen
und attraktiver machen wir wollen das
professorinnenprogramm
packen wir wollen
geschlechtergerechtigkeit und vielfalt
künftig in allen förderprogrammen und
institutionen verankern und durchsetzen
und durchsetzen mit einem bund länder
programm wollen wir best practice
projekte für 1 alternative karrieren
außerhalb der professur zwei wörter t
management drei moderne governance
personal und
organisationsstrukturen fördern
standards für führung und
compliance prozesse
sind im wissenschaftssystem noch stärker
zu berücksichtigen
internationale hochschulkooperation nie
war internationale kooperation wichtiger
daher räumen wir ihr einen hohen
stellenwert ein wir verteidigen
wissenschaftsfreiheit im in und ausland
stärken schutzprogramme werden die
internationalisierungs strategie im
dialog weiter entwickeln wir stärken
erasmus plus wir werden die europäischen
hochschul netzwerke mit weiteren
standorten und digital ausbauen bologna
kooperation mit nachbarländern vertiefen
wir um für internationale talente
attraktiv zu sein werden wir
administrative hürden abbauen und mit
einer plattform die rekrutierung von
internationalen spitzen
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern unterstützen wir werden
die institutionelle förderung von
deutschen akademischen austauschdienst
der ard und alexander von
humboldt-stiftung hvh analog zum pakt
für forschung und innovation
erhöhen asien und china kompetenz und
mir deutlich ausbauen
wissenschafts kommunikation und
partizipation
wissenschaft ist kein abgeschlossenes
system sondern lebt vom austausch und
der kommunikation mit der gesellschaft
wir wollen wissenschaftskommunikation
systematisch auf allen
wissenschaftlichen karriere stufen und
bei der bewilligung von fördermitteln
verankern wir setzen uns für die
förderung des wissenschaftsjournalismus
durch eine unabhängige stiftung
weiterbildung für
entscheidungsträgerinnen und
entscheidungsträger
analoge und digitale orte von forschungs
museen bis dashboards 1 wir werden mit
citizen science und bürger
wissenschaften perspektiven aus der
zivilgesellschaft stärker in die
forschung einbeziehen open access und
open science wollen wir stärken
drittens
klimaschutz in einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft
unsere wirtschaft legt mit ihren
unternehmen den beschäftigten sowie
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern die
grundlage für unseren wohlstand
als größte industrie und
exportwirtschaft europas steht
deutschland in den 2020er jahren jedoch
vor tiefgreifenden
transformationsprozess
im globalen wettbewerb von der
dekarbonisierung zur einhaltung des 15
grad
über die digitale transformation bis hin
zum demografischen wandel hinzu kommt
die lang anhaltende corona pandemie die
teile der wirtschaft vor große
herausforderungen stellt wir sehen
deshalb die aufgabe der ökonomischen
stärke unseres landes eine neue dynamik
zu verleihen
die wirtschaftskraft und der wohlstand
unseres landes liegen auch in zukunft in
der vielfalt von der industrie dem
mittelstand über das handwerk bis hin zu
handel und dienstleistungen wir stellen
die weichen auf eine sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft und leiten ein jahrzehnt
der zukunftsinvestitionen 1 damit legen
wir die grundlagen um nachhaltigen
wohlstand zu sichern und schaffen raum
für innovation
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und mehr effizienz
für gute arbeit sozialen aufstieg und
neue stärke wir denken ökonomische
entwicklung und ökologische
verantwortung zusammen es gilt zu
erhalten was uns erhält und unsere
ressourcen zu schützen der schutz von
umwelt und natur ist daher essentieller
bestandteil unseres politischen handelns
die 17 nachhaltigkeitsziele der
vereinten nationen erst deg sind
richtschnur unserer politik insbesondere
der kampf gegen das artensterben
verlangt hohe aufmerksamkeit und
politisches handeln unser ziel ist eine
nachhaltige zukunftsfähige
landwirtschaft in der die bäuerinnen und
bauern ökonomisch tragfähig wirtschaften
können und die umwelt tieren und klima
gerecht wird
wir stärken regionale
wertschöpfungsketten und tragen zum
erhalt ländlicher strukturen bei
wir wollen eine nachhaltige
barrierefreie innovative und für alle
alltagstauglich und bezahlbare mobilität
ermöglichen mobilität ist teil der
daseinsvorsorge und voraussetzung für
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse in
stadt und land
wirtschaft nach der korona pandemie
braucht deutschlands wirtschaft einen
neuen aufbruch
dafür muss die öffentliche hand impulse
setzen und faire rahmenbedingungen
national und im europäischen binnenmarkt
schaffen wir wollen mehr innovation mehr
wettbewerbsfähigkeit mehr effizienz gute
arbeit und klimaneutralen wohlstand
dafür brauchen wir ein jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen und mehr tempo
unser ziel ist eine sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft
industrie der industrie kommt eine
zentrale rolle bei der transformation
der wirtschaft mit blick auf klimaschutz
und digitalisierung zu
wir werden die innovations- investitions
und wettbewerbsfähigkeit der industrie
stärken um weiter hochtechnologie land
zu bleiben wir fördern regionale
transformations- cluster und werden
strukturschwache regionen unterstützt
unterstützen wir erarbeiten eine
industrie strategie die in verbindung
mit dem european green deal in einer
euro in eine europäische lösung
eingebettet ist durch geeignete
und durch geeignete maßnahmen haben
liegt verhindert um unsere heimische
industrie insbesondere die
grundstoffindustrie zu unterstützen
werden wir in dem für die erreichung der
klimaziele ausreichenden maße geeignete
instrumente schaffen beispielsweise
gaben contracts for difference klima
verträge cfd um so auch insbesondere die
wird mit
wirtschaftlichkeitslücke zu schließen
diese instrumente werden so ausgestaltet
dass die rückzahlungsphase mit
hinreichender wahrscheinlichkeit
erreicht werden wir unterstützen die
einführung eines europaweit wirksamen
co2 grenze ausgleichsmechanismus oder
vergleichbar wirksame instrumente
entscheidend ist dass dieser wto konform
ausgestaltet ist die exportindustrie
nicht benachteiligt greenwashing
verhindert und in unbürokratisch
innerhalb des bestehenden
emissionshandelssystems umgesetzt wird
setzen uns für die gründung einer
europäischen union für grünen
wasserstoff ein dazu wollen wir das pci
pci
wasserstoff schnell umsetzen und
investitionen in den aufbau einer
wasserstoff netzinfrastruktur finanziell
fördern so wollen wir bis 2030 leitmarkt
für wasserstoff technologien werden und
dafür ein ambitioniertes update der
nationalen wasserstoff strategie
erarbeiten
wir nutzen die europäische union und die
internationalen gremien gemeinsam mit
europäischen partnern für eine
initiative zur gründung eines für alle
staaten offenen internationalen klima
clubs mit einem einheitlichen co2
mindestpreis und einem gemeinsamen co2
grenze ausgleich geschaffen sicherer
absatzmärkte für klimafreundliche
produkte durch mindestquoten in der
öffentlichen beschaffung
die bundesregierung wird dafür sorge
tragen dass die wirtschaft
wettbewerbsfähige strompreise für
industrie unternehmen am standort
deutschland unter konsequenter nutzung
der eigenen potenziale erneuerbarer
energien bekommt die sie auf dem weg in
die klimaneutralität braucht neben dem
ausbau der infrastruktur werden wir die
ziele zur elektrolyse leistung deutlich
erhöhen europäische und internationale
klima
und energie partnerschaften für
klimaneutralen wasserstoff und seine
derivate auf augenhöhe vorantreiben und
quoten für grünen wasserstoff in der
öffentlichen beschaffung einführen um
leitmärkte zu schaffen wir fördern in
deutschland die produktion von grünem
wasserstoff im interesse eines zügigen
markthochlauf fördern wir zukunftsfähige
technologien auch dann wenn die
verfügbarkeit von grünem wasserstoff
noch nicht ausreichend sichergestellt
ist wir wollen den einsatz von
wasserstoff nicht auf bestimmte
anwendungsfelder begrenzen grüner
wasserstoff solle vorrangig in den
wirtschaftssektoren genutzt werden in
denen es nicht möglich ist verfahren und
prozesse durch eine direkte
elektrifizierung auf treibhausgas
neutralität umzustellen
deutschland sollte ein zentrum für
forschung fertigung und recycling von
batteriezellen werden gemeinsam mit
sozialpartnern und lokalen akteuren
bauen wir regionale transformations- und
qualifizierungs cluster auf
wir wollen deutschland zum globalen
standort der halbleiterindustrie machen
dazu soll die deutsche halbleiterbranche
entlang der gesamten wertschöpfungskette
auch finanziell hinreichend unterstützt
werden um diese schlüsseltechnologie
europa zu sichern zu stärken und
zukunftssicher auszubauen
transformationen der automobilindustrie
wir unterstützen die transformation des
automobilsektors um die klimaziele im
verkehrsbereich zu erreichen
arbeitsplätze sowie wertschöpfung
hierzulande zu erhalten wir machen
deutschland zum leitmarkt für
elektromobilität
zum innovationsstandort für autonomes
fahren und beschleunigen massiv den
ausbau der ladesäulen infrastruktur
unser ziel sind mindestens 15 millionen
vollelektrische pkw bis 2030 für die
wertschöpfung dieser deutschen
schlüsselindustrie ist die regionale
transformation der kmu ebenso von
zentraler bedeutung
wir werden daher den wandel in den
automobil regionen hin zu
elektromobilität durch gezielte cluster
forderungen unterstützen die fortführung
und weiterentwicklung der europäischen
batterie projekte wie pci
sowie die ansiedlung weiterer zell
produktionsstandorte einschließlich
recycling in deutschland sind von
zentraler bedeutung
dazu ist die stärkung der forschung an
neuen nachhaltigen batterie generationen
entscheidend wir wollen die auf
bundesebene bestehenden kooperations und
dialog formate im bereich
automobilwirtschaft in einer strategie
plattform chance von
transformation automobilwirtschaft mit
mobilitäts wirtschaft umwelt und
verkehrsverbänden sozialpartnern
wissenschaft bundestag ländern und
kommunalen spitzenverbänden mit den
zuständigen bundesressorts bündeln um
das ziel der klimaneutralität die
wertschöpfung sowie arbeits und
ausbildungsplätze zu sichern
luft und raumfahrt
raumfahrt und der bereich news pace sind
zentrale zukunftstechnologien wir
stärken das nationale raumfahrtprogramm
und die europäische weltraumorganisation
esa und bewahren ihre eigenständigkeit
wir entwickeln eine neue
raumfahrtstrategie
unter berücksichtigung der vermeidung
und bergung von weltraumschrott wir
stärken den luftfahrt
produktionsstandort deutschland wir
unterstützen die erforschung und den
markthochlauf von system von sind
ethischen kraftstoffe die klimaneutrales
fliegen ermöglichen
die auftrags verfahren im zusammenhang
mit dem luftfahrt forschungsprogramm für
entwicklung und einsatz digitaler
werkzeuge
prozessentwicklung materialforschung und
leichtbau sollen weiter beschleunigt
sowie vorauszahlungen ermöglicht werden
wir stärken die forschung zum einsatz
nachhaltiger kraftstoffe für leisere
antriebe sowie für eine plattform zur
simulation und optimierung des
gesamtsystems luftfahrt bezüglich seiner
klimawirkung
maritime wirtschaft
durch innovation und technologie
führerschaft sorgen wir für eine
wettbewerbsfähige maritime wirtschaft in
deutschland insbesondere bei
klimafreundlichen schiffsantrieben wir
bekennen uns zu den zielen der maritimen
agenda wir stärken den schiffbau über
die gesamte wertschöpfungskette
inklusive des schiffs recyclings als
industriellen kern in deutschland auf
europäischer ebene treten wir faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen und die
einsetzung eines europäischen flotten
modernisierungsprogramms ein
vergabeverfahren werden wir
beschleunigen unter der konsequenten
einstufen des marine unter und über
wasser schiffbaus sowie des behörden und
forschungsschiff baus als
schlüsseltechnologien inklusive der
instandhaltung wir werden eine
neukonzeptionierung der maritimen
ausbildung in kooperation mit den
bundesländern anstoßen wir setzen uns
für eine koordinierung des sediment
managements zwischen bund und ländern
ein wir wollen dass mehr schiffe unter
deutscher flagge fahren wir werden die
zollabwicklung beschleunigen
mittelstand handwerk und freie berufe
unsere wirtschaftspolitik setzt auf
zukunftsorientierte rahmenbedingungen
für einen wettbewerbsfähigen mittelstand
für ein starkes handwerk und für freie
berufe
hierfür werden wir die
beteiligungsmöglichkeiten von kleinen
und mittleren betrieben an
vergabeverfahren stärken förderprogramme
und investitionszuschüsse sollen vor
allem für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen und selbständige deutlich
einfacher zu beantragen und zu
dokumentieren sein dafür werden wir sie
digitalisieren evaluieren und
bedarfsgerecht ausgestalten zur
fachkräftesicherung im handwerk werden
wir das duale system der beruflichen
ausbildung verstärkt verstärken und den
übergang von der schule in die
berufliche bildung verbessern und im
rahmen eines ausbildungspakts
ausbildungsberuf schaffte rinnen und
botschafter fördern zudem wollen wir die
durchlässigkeit von beruflicher und
akademischer bildung verbessern die
ausbildung im handwerk werden wir
gezielt fördern zusätzlich wollen wir
eine begabtenförderung in der
beruflichen bildung einführen
wir wollen den zugang zur
meisterausbildung erleichtern indem wir
die kosten von meisterkursen und briefen
für die teilnehmer deutlich senken im
ausbildungsmarkt wollen wir menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte mit einer
förderinitiative stärken frauen im
handwerk werden wir stärken die
tarifbindung im handwerk und mittel und
mittelstand wollen wir stärken wir
wollen ehrenamtliche beteiligung und die
transparenz im kammer wesen im dialog
mit den sozialpartnern stärken
einzelhandel der stationäre handel in
deutschland braucht attraktive
rahmenbedingungen um im strukturwandel
gegenüber dem reinen online handel
bestehen und von der digitalisierung
profitieren zu können wir bemühen uns
weiter um fairen wettbewerb zwischen
geschäftsmodellen digitaler
großunternehmen und den lokal
verwurzelten unternehmen wir wollen die
digital gestützte wertschöpfung in
industrie handel handwerk und
dienstleistungen unterstützen und dafür
ein level playing field
herstellen benutzen das förderprogramm
zukunftsfähige innenstädte und zentren
und führen die innenstadt strategie des
bundes fort insbesondere das programm
lebendige zentren im rahmen der bund
länder städte bau im rahmen der bund
länder städtebauförderung
sie sollen für eine verbesserung der
aufenthalts- und erlebnisqualität in den
innenstädten genutzt werden wir werden
die konkreten rückzahlen modalitäten der
korona helfen prüfen
gesundheitswirtschaft
eine innovative gesundheitswirtschaft
ist grundlage des weiteren medizinischen
fortschritts und birgt gleichzeitig viel
potenzial für beschäftigung und
wohlstand
wir wollen weiter in forschung
investieren um medizinische
spitzenleistungen wie unter anderem
aktuell die anwendung der m rna
impfstoffe zu ermöglichen wir setzen uns
für heim medizintechnik made in germany
ein zugleich wollen wir die potenziale
der digitalisierung nutzen um eine
bessere versorgungsqualität zu erreichen
aber auch
effizienzpotenziale zu heben damit die
beschäftigten des gesundheitswesens die
digitale transformation bewältigen
können sind frühzeitige
weiterbildungsangebote unerlässlich
zugleich werden wir durch unsere
maßnahmen zur fachkräftesicherung dem
personalmangel im gesundheitswesen
entgegenwirken
tourismus der inländische tourismus ist
ein wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor mit
großem zukunftspotenzial besonders im
ländlichen raum wir nehmen den prozess
zur nationalen tourismus strategie
wieder auf verbessern die koordinierung
der tourismuspolitik um den
tourismusstandort deutschland nach der
korona krise nachhaltig klimafreundlich
sozial gerecht und innovativ zu
gestalten
mit einem modernisierungsprogramm
zukunft tourismus unterstützen wir
unbürokratisch neu und wieder gründungen
nationale naturlandschaften unesco
welterbe stätten
und unesco global geoparks sind wichtige
bestandteile des deutschen tourismus für
einen nachhaltigen naturverträglichen
tourismus unterstützen wir einen
verstärkten ausbau der passenden
infrastruktur besonders bei wander- rad-
und wassertourismus einen langfristigen
dialog zu den zukunftsthemen der branche
klimaneutralität digitalisierung
fachkräfte etablieren wir eine nationale
plattform zukunft des tourismus
wir schaffen die analoge meldepflicht
bei touristischen übernachtungen
womöglich im bundes meldegesetz ab der
umgang mit meldeschein wird künftig
komplett digital erfolgen wir werden die
gewinnung ausländischer fachkräfte für
die deutsche tourismusbranche durch den
abbau bürokratischer hürden erleichtern
startup gründungs und
innovationsförderung wir stärken die
startup und gründer förderung wir werden
gründungen aus allen lebenslagen und
eine kultur der zweiten chance
unterstützen und dafür ein neues
förderinstrument schaffen das auch für
in unternehmensnachfolgen offensteht wir
verabschieden eine umfassende start up
strategie würden für frauen und menschen
mit migrationshintergrund beim zugang zu
finanzierungen und förderungen bauen wir
ab besseren zugang zu wagniskapital für
gründerinnen stellen wir sicher wir
ermöglichen einen vereinfachten
rechtssicheren zugang für start ups und
junge unternehmen zu öffentlichen
aufträgen wir schaffen die
voraussetzungen für flächendeckende one
stop shops also anlaufstellen für
gründungsberatung förderung und
anmeldung ziel ist es
unternehmensgründungen innerhalb von 24
stunden zu ermöglichen die staatliche
förderbank kfw
solle stärker als innovations- und
investitionsprogramm
titelgeber wirken insbesondere für ki
quantentechnologie
wasserstoff medizin nachhaltige
mobilität bioökonomie und
kreislaufwirtschaft wir wollen
ermöglichen dass privates kapital
institutionelle anleger wie
versicherungen und pensionskassen
für die startfinanzierung mobilisiert
werden kann wir wollen die beteiligung
von frauen in investment komitees von
staatlichen fonds und
beteiligungsgesellschaften deutlich
stärken die
mitarbeiterkapitalbeteiligung werden wir
attraktiver machen unter anderem durch
eine weitere anhebung des
steuerfreibetrags zu einer modernen
unternehmenskultur gehören auch neue
formen wie sozialunternehmen oder
gesellschaften mit gebundenen vermögen
wir erarbeiten eine nationale strategie
für sozialunternehmen um gemeinwohl
orientierte unternehmen und soziale
innovationen stärker zu unterstützen
wir verbessern die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen für gemeinwohl
orientiertes wirtschaften wie zum
beispiel für genossenschaften
sozialunternehmen
integrationsunternehmen für unternehmen
mit gebundenen vermögen wollen wir eine
neue geeignete rechtsgrundlage schaffen
die steuer spar konstruktionen
ausschließt hemmnisse beim zugang zur
finanzierung und förderung bauen wir ab
wir werden die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen schaffen um guthaben
auf verwaisten konnten zur förderung des
gemeinwohls nutzen zu können es schaffen
neues zutrauen in gründergeist
innovation und unternehmertum dazu
stärken und entbürokratisieren wir die
innovationsförderung und finanzierung
die förderprogramme wie zentrales
innovationsprogramm mittelstand
ctm
industrielle gemeinschaftsforschung für
unternehmen gft com go digital und
digital jetzt sowie das
innovationsprogramm für geschäftsmodelle
und pionier lösungen ii gp wenn wir
weiter entwickeln die
innovationsförderung des bundes soll für
soziale und ökologische innovationen
konsequent geöffnet werden die
förderprogramme sollen bedarfsgerecht
und flexibel ausgestattet und dynamisch
fortgeschrieben werden wir werden ein
real labor und freiheits zonen gesetz
schaffen das einheitliche und
innovationsfreundliche rahmenbedingungen
für real labore bietet und neue
freiräume zur erprobung von innovationen
ermöglicht das gesetz soll unter anderem
übergreifende standards für real labore
und experimentier klauseln gesetzlich
verankern die unternehmen
forschungsinstituten und kommunen
attraktive bedingungen bieten und
gleichzeitig regulatorisches lernen
fördern wir wollen im rahmen der
bestehenden förderstrukturen auch die
entwicklungsschritte von der innovation
hin zum markteintritt unterstützen
einen moment bitte
[Musik]
fairer wettbewerb wir verbessern die
rahmenbedingungen für fairen wettbewerb
diese müssen auch den erfordernissen des
mittelstands rechnung tragen und die
aspekte innovation nachhaltigkeit
verbraucherschutz und soziale
gerechtigkeit integrieren wir werden das
gesetz gegen wettbewerbsbeschränkungen
gwb
evaluieren und weiterentwickeln wir
werden prüfen wie das bundeskartellamt
gestärkt werden kann um bei erheblichen
dauerhaften und wiederholten verstößen
gegen normen des wirtschaftlichen
verbraucherrechts analog zu verstößen
gegen das gwb verstöße zu ermitteln und
diese abzustellen wir werden das
ministererlaubnis verfahren so
reformieren dass wieder angemessene
klagemöglichkeiten gegen eine
ministererlaubnis bestehen und der
deutsche bundestag im verfahren
beteiligt wird
wir setzen uns für eine missbrauchs
unabhängige entflechtung möglichkeit auf
europäischer ebene als ultima ratio
verfestigten märkten ein wir wollen eine
verpflichtung zur interoperabilität
auf europäischer ebene und über das gwb
für marktbeherrschende unternehmen
verankern dabei sollen basierend auf
internationalen technischen standards
das kommunikations geheimnis ein hoher
datenschutz und hoher it sicherheit
sowie eine durchgängige
ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung
sichergestellt werden die daten
portabilität soll gestärkt werden auf eu
ebene setzen wir uns außerdem für eine
verabschiedung eines ambitionierten
digital.de titel markets act dna sowie
seine durchsetzung durch die
wettbewerbsbehörden der mitgliedstaaten
ein auf europäischer ebene werden wir
uns für eine anpassung der
fusionskontrolle zur unterbindung
innovations- hemmender strategischer
aufkäufe potenzieller wettbewerber so
genannte killer accusations
einsetzen
bürokratieabbau
wir wollen abläufe und regeln
vereinfachen
und der wirtschaft insbesondere den
selbstständigen unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern mehr zeit für ihre
eigentlichen aufgaben schaffen
wir werden ein neues bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz auf den weg bringen
welches die wirtschaft bürgerinnen und
bürger sowie verwaltung gegenüber dem
bisherigen bürokratie aufwand entlastet
ohne auf notwendige schutzstandards zu
verzichten überflüssige bürokratie
werden wir abbauen
die ressort übergreifende man in one out
regelung setzen wir konsequent fort die
bundesregierung wird ein systematisches
verfahren zur überprüfung des
bürokratischen aufwands von gesetzen und
regelungen entwickeln dass eine
regelmäßige einbeziehung des stakeholder
vorsieht
praxis check
wir werden bei der umsetzung von
eu-recht dafür sorge tragen dass sie
effektiv bürokratie arm und im sinne des
einheitlichen europäischen binnenmarktes
erfolgt wir werden das one sony prinzip
schnellstmöglich einführen
das bereits beschlossene unternehmens
basisdaten register soll schnell
umgesetzt und dessen finanzierung
gesichert werden wenn prüfen inwiefern
wir den aufwand für und durch die rein
elektronische aufbewahrung von belegen
und geschäftsunterlagen verringern
können
unnötige erfordernisse bei a1
bescheinigungen bei
grenzüberschreitenden
dienstleistungserbringung müssen rasch
abgeschafft werden in dem ein
europäisches
elektronisches echtzeit register
eingeführt wird
das postgesetz wollen wir novellieren
und dabei sozial ökologische standards
weiter entwickeln sowie den fairen
wettbewerb stärken wir nutzen das
bundesfinanzierung gremium um regelmäßig
zu überprüfen ob die mit der beteiligung
verfolgten ziele auch erreicht werden
und ob sie noch zur öffentlichen
daseinsvorsorge benötigt werden
wir wollen im jahreswirtschaftsbericht
eine wohlstands berichterstattung
integrieren die neben ökonom mission
auch ökologische soziale und
gesellschaftliche dimensionen des
wohlstands erfasst wir werden die
wissenschaftlichen beratungsgremien der
bundesregierung nach dem vorbild der
monopolkommission stärken und deren
unabhängigkeit garantieren die berichte
der sachverständigen räte werden wir
nach ihrer veröffentlichung im bundestag
als eigenständigen tagesordnungspunkt
diskutieren
fachkräfte
der mangel an qualifizierten fachkräften
in vielen branchen kann eines der
größten hindernisse für
wirtschaftswachstum für die sicherung
von wohlstand eine hohe qualität in
gesundheit pflege betreuung und bildung
sowie für das gelingen der
transformation in deutschland sein die
bundesregierung wird daher ihre
fachkräfte strategie und die nationale
weiter bildungsstrategie
weiterentwickeln wesentliche bausteine
sind
ersten streben wir eine höhere
erwerbsbeteiligung von frauen an diesem
ziel dient unsere arbeitsmarkt
gleichstellungs und familienpolitik
zweitens wollen wir allen älteren
erwerbstätigen die dies können und
wollen ermöglichen auch mindestens bis
zum regulären renteneintrittsalter zu
arbeiten drittens brauchen wir einen
neuen schub für berufliche aus- fort-
und weiterbildung oder neuorientierung
auch in der mitte des erwerbslebens vor
allem dann wenn der technologische
wandel dies erfordert viertens
braucht deutschland mehr arbeitskräfte
einwanderungen wir werden unser
einwanderungsrecht weiterentwickeln und
bewahrt bewährte ansätze des fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetzes wie die westbalkan
regelung entfristen
neben dem bestehenden einwanderungsrecht
werden wir mit der einführung einer
chancen karte auf basis eines
punktesystems eine zweite säule
etablieren um arbeitskräften zur
jobsuche den gesteuerten zugang zum
deutschen arbeitsmarkt zu ermöglichen
die blue card werden wir im nationalen
recht auf nicht akademische berufe
ausweiten voraussetzung wird ein
konkretes jobangebot zu marktüblichen
konditionen seien
zugleich werden wir die hürden bei der
anerkennung von bildungs und
berufsabschlüssen aus dem ausland
absenken
bürokratie abbauen und verfahren
beschleunigen fünftens müssen
arbeitsbedingungen in den bereichen
attraktiver werden in denen bereits
jetzt oder absehbar ein mangel an
fachkräften herrscht
vergaberecht wir wollen die öffentlichen
vergabeverfahren vereinfachen
professionalisieren digitalisieren und
beschleunigen die bundesregierung wird
die öffentliche beschaffen und vergabe
wirtschaftlich sozial ökologisch und
innovativ ausrichten und die
verbindlichkeit stärken ohne dabei die
rechtssicherheit von
vergabeentscheidungen zu gefährden oder
die zugangshürden für den mittelstand zu
erhöhen wir werden die bestehenden
anforderungen entsprechend des
europäischen vergaberechts im nationalen
vergaberecht präzisieren die öffentliche
hand soll sich am aufbau eines systems
zur berechnung von klima und umwelt
kosten beteiligen wir wollen die
rechtssichere digitalisierung in diesem
bereich vorantreiben und dazu eine
anwenderfreundliche zentrale plattform
schaffen
über die alle öffentlichen vergaben
zugänglich sind und die eine
präqualifizierung der unternehmen
ermöglicht wir wollen schnelle
entscheidungen bei vergabeverfahren der
öffentlichen hand fördern und
unterstützen dabei länder und kommunen
bei der vereinfachung
digitalisierung und nachhaltigkeit
rohstoffe lieferketten und freihandel
wir wollen unsere wirtschaft bei der
sicherung einer nachhaltigen
rohstoffversorgung unterstützen den
heimischen rohstoffabbau erleichtern und
ökologisch ausrichten
wir wollen das bundes bergrecht
modernisieren
wollen das ökonomische und ökologische
potenzial des recyclings umfassend
nutzen den ressourcen verbrauch senken
und damit arbeitsplätze schaffen
produktdesign
recycler
recycling
die genehmigungsprozesse für ungebundene
finanzkredite werden wir beschleunigen
ohne nachhaltigkeitsstandards zu senken
wir unterstützen ein wirksames eu
lieferketten gesetz basierend auf den un
leitprinzipien wirtschaft und
menschenrechte das kleinere und mittlere
unternehmen nicht überfordert das gesetz
über die unternehmerischen
sorgfaltspflichten in lieferketten wird
unverändert umgesetzt und gegebenenfalls
verbessert wir unterstützen den
vorschlag der eu-kommission zum gesetz
für ein für entwaldung freie
lieferketten wir unterstützen das von
der eu vorgeschlagene importverbot von
produkten aus zwangsarbeit
wir wollen den regelbasierten freihandel
auf grundlage von fairen sozialen
ökologischen und menschenrechtlichen
standards stärken
und sprechen uns für eine deutsche und
europäische handelspolitik gegen
protektionismus und unfaire
handelspraktiken aus damit garantieren
wir wohlstand und nachhaltiges
wirtschaftswachstum wir setzen uns für
die stärkung des multilateralismus und
für die weiterentwicklung der
welthandelsorganisation wto ein dazu
gehört die erneuerung der regeln zum
markt verzerren subventionen die
aufhebung der blockade bei dem
streitbeilegung mechanismus und eine
ausrichtung am pariser klimavertrag
sowie den globalen nachhaltigkeitszielen
der vn wir unterstützen die neue
ausrichtung der eu handelsstrategie und
wollen die künftigen eu handelsabkommen
unter anderem mit vielen neuseeland
australien asien
indien mit einer effektiven
nachhaltigkeits standards unter
anwendung eines streitbeilegung
mechanismus ausstatten wir setzen uns
auf europäischer ebene dafür ein
dass bei der vertrags fortentwicklung
durch die regulatorische kooperation die
entscheidungskompetenzen des eu
parlaments gestärkt werden wir nutzen
das europäische wettbewerbsrecht und die
stärke des europäischen binnenmarktes
gerade mit blick auf unfaire
wettbewerbspraktiken autoritärer regime
wir unterstützen die schaffung und
weiterentwicklung der autonomen
handelspolitischen instrumente gegen
unfaire handelspraktiken auf
europäischer ebene die
kreditabsicherungen für exporte in vor
von hermes bürgschaften unterstützen wir
gerade auch für kmu es bei small ticket
finanzierung gleichzeitig sollten sie
klimapolitischen zielen nicht
entgegenstehen
europa sollte die chance ergreifen in
einen intensiven austausch mit der neuen
us regierung zur förderung von handel
und investitionen mit hohen umwelt- und
sozialstandards einzutreten um mit dem
transatlantischen wirtschaftsraum
globale standard setzen zu können
gemeinsam mit den usa wollen wir den
multilateralen handel die reform der wwu
die etablierung von ökologischen und
sozialen standards den wohlstand sowie
die dynamik eines nachhaltigen
welthandels vorantreiben wir setzen uns
für ein ambitioniertes abkommen mit den
usa ein das einen rechtssicheren und
datenschutzkonformen datentransfer auf
europäischen schutzniveau ermöglicht
die entscheidung über die ratifizierung
des umfassenden wirtschafts und
handelsabkommens zeta treffen wir nach
abschluss der prüfung durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht
wir setzen uns dann für die
ratifizierung des mercosur abkommens ein
wenn zuvor von seiten der partnerländer
umsetzbare und überprüfbare rechtliche
verbindliche verpflichtungen zum umwelt-
sozial- und menschenrechtsschutz
eingegangen werden und praktisch
durchsetzbare zusatzvereinbarungen zum
schutz und erhalt bestehender
waldflächen abgeschlossen worden sind
eine ratifikation des eu-china
investitionsabkommen es im eu rat kann
aus verschiedenen gründen zurzeit nicht
stattfinden
wir werden uns für reziprozität
einsetzen wir setzen uns für
investitionsabkommen ein die den
investitionsschutz für unternehmen im
ausland auf direkte enteignungen und
diskriminierungen konzentrieren und
wollen die mil die missbräuchliche
anwendung des instruments auch bei den
noch ausstehenden abkommen verhindern
die gesellschaft für außenwirtschaft und
standortmarketing
german trade investment
gti und das netz der außenhandelskammern
werden wir stärken wir wollen prüfen ob
bei klar definierten sicherheits
gefährdungen durch die übernahme
kritischer infrastrukturen zb im
deutschen stromnetz oder im
breitbandnetz durch ausländische
investoren das rechtliche
instrumentarium
ausreicht und gegebenenfalls
geeignete instrumente dafür schaffen
damit die bundesregierung angemessen und
schnell reagieren kann
regionale wirtschaftsförderung
im rahmen des gesamtdeutschen
fördersystems werden wir die mittel für
die gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
wirtschaftsentwicklung für
innovationsförderung
digitalisierung betriebliche produkte
produktivitätsziele nachhaltigkeit und
dekarbonisierung aufstocken dabei soll
die bestehende 50 km regen 50 kilometer
regelungen überprüft und gegebenenfalls
abgeschafft werden ziel ist es damit für
zusätzliche regionale wachstumsimpulse
zu sorgen wir werden die erfahrungen mit
diesem instrument nutzen um das gesamte
fördersystem des bundes in zukunft noch
stärker auf die herstellung
gleichwertiger lebensverhältnisse und
die transformation der
wirtschaftsstruktur auszurichten
alle ressorts werden ihre
förderrichtlinien überprüfen alle
ressorts werden die regionale verteilung
ihrer förderprogramme offen legen und
dazu einheitliche daten standards
etablieren wir streben eine ausgewogene
regionale verteilung von
außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen auch innerhalb
der großen wissenschafts und
forschungsorganisationen an den ausbau
und die neuansiedlung von
außeruniversitären einrichtungen
unterstützen wir prioritär in den
regionen die gegenwärtig unter
ausgestattet sind so wie zum beispiel
viele teile ostdeutschlands
umwelt und naturschutz
die 17 global nachhaltigkeitsziele der
vereinten nationen es deg sind
richtschnur unserer politik damit
schützen wir die freiheit und chancen
jetziger und kommender generationen
wir werden die deutschen
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie und das
maßnahmenprogramm
nachhaltigkeit weiterentwickeln und die
governance strukturen überprüfen
wir erhöhen die verbindlichkeit von
nachhaltigkeitsstrategien zielen und
programmen im konkreten
regierungshandeln und bei der erstellung
von gesetzen und stärken
parlamentarischen beteiligungsrechte die
öffentliche hand geht bei ihrer
beschaffung mit gutem beispiel voran
naturschutz und biodiversität der
erhalt der artenvielfalt
ist eine menschheitsaufgabe und eine
ethische verpflichtung wir wollen die
biologische vielfalt schützen und
verbessern ihre nachhaltige nutzung
sichern und die potenziale des
natürlichen klimaschutzes nutzen dafür
bringen wir uns ambitioniert auf
internationaler ebene ein stärken den
naturschutz und seen kooperation mit den
flächen nutzern als zentralen baustein
an den notwendigen maßnahmen werden wir
ergreifen und finanzieren auf der
biodiversitätskonferenz
setzen wir uns für einen ambitionierten
neuen globalen rahmen ein wir werden
unser finanzielles engagement zur
umsetzung des globalen rahmens erheblich
erhöhen
wir setzen uns im rahmen der konvention
über biologische vielfalt cbd
im sinne der europäischen
biodiversitätsstrategie dafür 1 30%
schutzgebiete zu erreichen und diese
wirksam zu schützen für die nationale
umsetzung werden wir die nationale
strategie zur biologischen vielfalt
nbs mit aktionsplänen konkreten zielen
und maßnahmen weiter entwickeln
verbindlich verankern und das
wissenschaftliche monitoring stärken
wir unterstützen die ausweisung des
europäischen grünen bandes und
berücksichtigen dabei auch die
erinnerungskultur und begangenes
sed-unrecht wir legen einen
aktionsplan schutzgebiete auf mit dem
ziel ihr management zu verbessern
bundeseigene flächen im außenbereich
haben für den klimaschutz sowohl als
potenzielle standorte für windkraft und
pv anlagen als auch für die
biodiversität wie zum beispiel
biotopverbund
tschuldigung zum wie zum beispiel
biotopverbund nationales naturerbe
wildnisgebiete gewässer und artenschutz
eine erhebliche bedeutung und können die
entwicklung im ländlichen raum
unterstützen und einer nachhaltigen
nutzung zur verfügung stehen hierfür
geeignete flächen werden künftig von der
privatisierung ausgenommen und der
bundesanstalt für immobilienaufgaben
übertragen soweit sie sich noch nicht in
deren eigentum befinden
die bundesanstalt verpachtet diese
flächen und flächen aus ihrem eigenen
bestand dauerhaft für den jeweiligen
zweck die bvvg flächen die zur
übertragung in das nationale naturerbe
beim bundesamt für naturschutz
vorbereitet und gelistet sind werden
zügig übertragen und so entwickeln
entwickelt dass sie ihre funktion als
co2 senken erhöhen
das europäische naturschutzrecht setzen
wir eins zu eins um
für die umsetzung von
naturschutzmaßnahmen oberhalb von
gesetzlichen mindeststandards
stärken wir den vertrags den
vertragsnaturschutz deutlich und
ermöglichen regionale spielräume sowie
flexible lösungen wie den
niederländischen weg wir stärken den
naturschutz in der gemeinschaftsaufgabe
agrarstruktur und küstenschutz gak und
erhöhen die mittel auch für die
vertragsnaturschutz programme der länder
die energiewende werden wir ohne den
abbau von ökologischen schutzstandards
schutzstandards forcieren wir werden ein
nationales alten hilfsprogramm auf legen
dass insbesondere den schutz derjenigen
arten verbessert weil denen es konflikte
mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
gibt um die energiewende
naturverträglich zu gestalten und die
finanzierung mit beteiligung der
betreiber sicherstellen
wir setzen uns für konsequenten
insektenschutz 1 denn den einsatz von
pestiziden deutlich verringern und die
entwicklung von natur und
umweltverträglichen alternativen fördern
den kampf gegen die wilderei wollen wir
intensivieren
und den illegalen handel mit geschützten
arten auch im online handel unterbinden
sowie den vollzug durch eine taskforce
stärken wir setzen uns für ein
importverbot von wildfängen für den
heimtiermarkt 1
unser ziel ist es das zusammenleben von
weidetieren mensch und wolf so gut zu
gestalten
dass trotz noch steigender wolfs
population möglichst wenige konflikte
auftreten
wir werden mit allen in diesen fragen
befassten organisationen und verbänden
einen institutionalisierten dialog weil
die tierhaltung und wolf einrichten wir
werden durch eine überarbeitung des der
monitoring standards die anzahl der in
deutschland lebenden wölfe
realitätsgetreu abbilden und wollen den
ländern europarechtskonform ein regional
differenziertes bestandsmanagement
ermöglichen
natürlicher klimaschutz
wir entwickeln ein aktionsprogramm
natürlicher klimaschutz mit dem wir
synergien zwischen natur und klimaschutz
schaffen und stärken mit renaturierungs
renaturierungsmaßnahmen die residenz
unserer ökosysteme
insbesondere moore wälder owen grünland
sowie marino und küstenschutz thema
gegen die klimakrise wir stellen eine
ausreichende finanzierung aus dem
energie und klimafonds bereit zusätzlich
richten wir einen bundes naturschutz
verein und bündeln die bestehenden
bundesprogramme zum naturschutz
moorschutz liegt im öffentlichen
interesse wir werden eine nationale
moorschutz strategie verabschieden und
zügig umsetzen wir werden die umsetzung
von moa schutzmaßnahmen durch einen
partizipativen prozess zur erarbeitung
nachhaltige entwicklungskonzepte
begleiten perspektiven für die region
entwickeln und alternative
bewirtschaftungsformen stärken unter
anderem paar rudi
palla die kulturen
wir werden alternativen zur torf nutzung
entwickeln und beschließen einen
ausstiegsplan für torfabbau und
verwendung
das bestehende naturerbe an oder und
mittelelbe schützen wir die kompetenzen
der bundeswasserstraßen und
schifffahrtsverwaltung wsv für
klimaschutz und klimaanpassung werden
wir stärken die natürliche co2
speicherfähigkeit der meere werden wir
durch ein gezieltes aufbauprogramm
verbessern seegraswiesen algen wälder
gerade wald werden die folgen der
klimakrise sichtbar gleichzeitig ist er
für das erreichen unserer
klimaschutzziele
unerlässlich durch einen gezielten
waldumbau müssen artenreicher und klima
residente wälder mit überwiegend
standort heimischen baumarten geschaffen
werden die waldbewirtschaftung spielt
dabei eine wichtige rolle entsprechend
dieser ziele novellieren wir das
waldgesetz wir werden das forstschäden
ausgleichs gesetz evaluieren und
passendes gegebenenfalls an
intervalle und form der
bundeswaldinventur wenn wir überprüfen
und ein digitales wald monitoring
einführen der bund wird zusammen mit den
ländern einen langfristigen ansatz
entwickeln der konkrete über die
bisherigen zertifizierungssysteme
hinausgehende anforderungen an
zusätzlicher klimaschutz und
biodiversität leistungen adressiert
diese honoriert und die waldbesitzer
dadurch in die lage versetzt ihre wälder
klima resilient weiterzuentwickeln und
wenn nötig um zu bauen oder neu und
wiederbewaldung zu unterstützen wir
stoppen den einschlag in alten
naturnahen buchen will dann in
öffentlichen besitz
die wälder im bundesbesitz sollen
mittelfristig mindestens nach fsc oder
naturland standards bewirtschaftet
werden wir fördern den internationalen
waldschutz und diewald renaturierung wir
setzen uns auf eu-ebene für eine
rechtlich verbindliche regelung ein die
den import von produkten und rohstoffen
die mit entwaldung verbunden sind
verhindert mit einer holzbau initiative
unterstützen wir die regionalen holz
wertschöpfungsketten wir wollen die
kaskadennutzung als grundsatz verankern
wir stärken forstwirtschaftliche
zusammenschlüsse
wir werden bundesweite präventions- und
bekämpfungsstrategien erarbeiten und die
waldbrandbekämpfung möglichkeiten am
boden und aus der luft auch im rahmen
des mechanismus rest eu ausbauen wir
fördern bodenschonende wald bearbeitung
zum beispiel wie die rückepferde und
sattgrünen
meeresschutz
intakte meere
sind maßgeblich für klimaschutz und
biodiversität schutz sicherheit und
nachhaltige nutzung der ozeane wollen
wir miteinander in einklang bringen wir
starten eine meeres offensive zum schutz
der meere es natur
erarbeiten eine kohärente und
verbindliche meeres strategie richten
eine meeres koordination unter leitung
einer meeres beauftragten ein und
etablieren eine nationale meeres
konferenz wir wollen die
ökosystemleistungen von nord und ostsee
erhalten dafür werden wir die
schutzgebiete in der deutschen außen-
wirtschaftszone awz
effektiv managen und die dafür
notwendigen personellen und
infrastrukturellen ressourcen zur
verfügung stellen
zehn prozent der awz werden wir gemäß
der eu biodiversitätsstrategie strengen
schützen und dort zonen frei von
schädlichen nutzung ausweisen wir setzen
uns für den zügigen abschluss eines vn
abkommens zum schutz der biodiversität
auf hoher see für ein international
verbindliches rahmenwerk gegen die
vermüllung der meere und für die
einrichtung von internationalen
schutzgebieten insbesondere dem weddell
meer ein wir setzen uns für ein verbot
von scheuer fäden so genannten dollar
auf
europäischer ebene ein für die bergung
und vernichtung von munitions altlasten
in der nord und ostsee wird ein sofort
programm aufgelegt sowie ein bund länder
für die mittel- und langfristige bergung
eingerichtet und solide finanziert wir
setzen uns international für strenge
umweltstandards und die verbindliche
überprüfung der umweltverträglichkeit im
die tiefsee bergbau ein und werden die
meeresforschung fortführen um das wissen
über die tiefsee auszuweiten wir wollen
keine neuen genehmigungen für öl und gas
bohren bohrungen jenseits der erteilten
rahmen betriebserlaubnis für die
deutsche nord- und ostsee
erteilen
[Applaus]
klimaanpassung
wir erarbeiten eine vorsorgende klima
anpassungsstrategie insbesondere auch
vor dem hintergrund der flutkatastrophe
mit einem klima anpassungs gesetz
schaffen wir einen rahmen um gemeinsam
mit den ländern eine
nationale klima anpassungsstrategie mit
messbaren zielen etwa in den
handlungsfeldern hitze vorsorge
gesundheits und allergieprävention und
wasserinfrastruktur umzusetzen und
rechtzeitig nach steuern zu können
erster dringliche maßnahmen werden wir
zudem mit einem sofortprogramm sehr
schnell auf den weg bringen wir streben
eine verankerung der gemeinsamen
finanzierung von bund und ländern zur
klima vorsorge und klimaanpassung an und
wollen sie mit ausreichend finanziellen
mitteln ausstatten wir schaffen mehr
raum für innovation digitalisierung und
privatwirtschaftliche initiativen für
klimaanpassung
[Musik]
den küsten und hochwasserschutz
verstehen wir als
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe und
werden die länder und kommunen
finanziell stärken wir schaffen
bundeseinheitliche standards für die
bewertung von hochwasser und starkregen
risiken und die erstellung und
veröffentlichung von gefahren und risiko
karten
wir überprüfen den ausnahmekatalog für
die genehmigung von bauvorhaben in
ausgewiesenen
überschwemmungsgebieten und passen ihnen
wenn nötig an mit dem ziel risiken zu
minimieren
ja unterstützen privathaushalte mit
einer kfw förderung bei der privaten
hochwasser und starkregen vorsorge wir
unterstützen kommunen bei investitionen
in klima resilienz insbesondere in eine
klima feste wasserinfrastruktur
die extremen niederschlägen und
niedrigwasser rechnung trägt
mit entsiegelung projekten stärken wie
die versickerung von regenwasser
und reduzieren die risiken von schwimmen
wasserschutz
gemeinsam mit den ländern
setzen wir die eu-wasserrahmenrichtlinie
zum schutz des wassers als öffentliches
gut konsequent und zügig um wir setzen
zügig eine von bund und ländern
gemeinsam getragene nationale
wasserstrategie mit dem ziel eines
integrierten wassermanagements um
gemeinsam mit den ländern entwickeln wir
eine leitlinie zur wasserentnahme
die der öffentlichen
trinkwasserversorgung den vorrang
einräumt
für die wiederverwendung von abwasser
streben wir die rasche umsetzung der
europäischen vorgaben
und eine sichere und rechtssichere
ausgestaltung an wir werden das abwasser
abgabengesetz mit dem ziel der
verbesserung des gewässerschutzes
novellieren wir setzen anreize um
gewässer verunreinigungen effizient zu
vermeiden
wir wollen die verwendung
wassergefährdender gefährden der stoffe
in den zeugnissen zum schutz vor
inakzeptablen risiken auf essentielle
verwendung beschränken wir verbessern
den wissensstand über die gewässer
gewässer qualitäten in deutschland mit
validierten daten unter anderem der wand
der wasserversorger und führen ein
digitales mapping ein wir verankern eine
umwelt qualitätsnorm für
arzneimittelwirkstoffe im wasserrecht um
stoff einträge differenziert beurteilen
zu können
unterstützen ein europäisches verbot von
bewusst beigefügte micro plastik in
kosmetika und waschmittel und von
flüssigen polymeren stoffe im abwasser
können auch rohstoffe seien die im sinne
der kreislaufwirtschaft genutzt werden
sollten
wir ergreifen alle notwendigen maßnahmen
um europa rechtliche verpflichtungen zur
minderung von stickstoff einträgen in
wasser und luft sicher zu erreichen
und wenden damit strafzahlungen an die
eu ab
[Applaus]
luftreinhaltung
wir wollen die luftbelastung weiter
reduzieren um die menschliche gesundheit
und die umwelt nachhaltig zu schützen
wir unterstützen das vorhaben der
europäischen kommission die eu
luftqualitätsrichtlinie zu novellieren
um schrittweise neueste standards zu
erreichen wir werden für transparenz bei
ablassen von kerosin sorge
und möglichkeiten der vermeidung
entwickeln kommunen werden wir auf dem
weg zu besserer luftqualität
unterstützen bvt schlussfolgerungen
setzen wir fristgerecht und nachhaltig
um
und die minderungsziele aus der
richtlinie über nationale
emissionshöchstmengen
fristgerecht zu erreichen setzen im
nationalen luftreinhalte programm alle
erforderlichen maßnahmen um
bodenschutz des
bundes bodenschutz recht werden wir
evaluieren
und an die herausforderungen des
klimaschutzes der klimaanpassung und den
erhalt der biodiversität anpassen und
dabei die unterschiedlichen nutzungen
berücksichtigen auf eu ebene werden wir
uns für einen verbesserten schutz der
böden und
verbindliche regelungen einsetzen wir
werden ein nationales boden monitoring
zentrum einrichten
um den flächenverbrauch für siedlungs-
und verkehrszwecke auf das 30 hektar
ziel bis spätestens
2030 zu reduzieren werden wir anreize
setzen
fehlanreiz fehlanreize vermeiden und
durch wirksame initiativen versiegelung
reduzieren
chemikalienpolitik
die chemieindustrie steht in einem
weltweiten wettbewerb
wir stärken ihre wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und innovationskraft
nachhaltigkeit und klimaschutz sowie den
produktionsstandort deutschland
sichern arbeitsplätze und reduzieren die
risiken des einsatzes
gesundheitsgefährdende stoffe zb per und
pulli fluorid chemikalien wir bringen
uns entsprechend konstruktiv in die
debatte um die eu chemikalien strategie
ein in diesem sinne wollen wir
richards eu verordnung zur registrierung
bewertung zulassung und beschränkung
chemischer stoffe weiter entwickeln
wobei stoffe und stoffgruppen auf ihre
risiken hin bewertet werden nach einer
risikobewertung im kontext der anwendung
kann eine zulassung erfolgen wir
erarbeiten einen nationalen plan zum
schutz vor hormonaktiven substanzen wir
schützen unsere unternehmen sowie
verbraucher und verbraucherinnen besser
vor importen die den eu standards nicht
entsprechen indem wir gemeinsam mit den
ländern den vollzug bei der kontrolle
stärken und produktrückrufe erleichtern
wir werden das human biomonitoring
stärken und eine kontinuierliche
finanzierung sicherstellen für eine
umfassende bewertung von stoffen und die
entwicklung von nachhaltigen chemikalien
stärken wir die forschung und den
produktionsstandort deutschland
kreislaufwirtschaft
wir fördern die kreislaufwirtschaft als
effektiven klima und ressourcenschutz
chance für nachhaltige
wirtschaftsentwicklung und arbeitsplätze
wir haben das ziel der senkung des
primären rohstoffverbrauch und
geschlossener stoffkreisläufe
hierzu passen wir den bestehenden
rechtlichen rahmen an definieren klare
ziele und überprüfen abfallrechtliche
vorgaben in einer nationalen kreislauf
wirtschaftsstrategie bündeln wir
bestehende rohstoff politische
strategien
auf dieser grundlage setzen uns in der
eu für einheitliche standards ein
anforderungen an produkte müssen
europaweit im dialog mit den herstellern
ambitioniert und einheitlich festgelegt
werden produkte müssen langlebig wieder
verwendbar
recyclebar und möglichst
reparierbar sein wir stärken die
erweiterte hersteller verantwortung auf
europäischer ebene gehören digitale
produkt besser ein
unterstützen unternehmen bei der
umsetzung und waren das prinzip der
datensparsamkeit
wir stärken die abfallvermeidung durch
gesetzliche ziele und ökologisch
vorteilhafte mehrweg rücknahme und fand
systeme sowie branchen vereinbarungen
hierbei unterstützen wir innovative
nachhaltige ideen wie geteilte nutzung
wir etablieren ein anreizsystem um
bestimmte elektrogeräte und gefährliche
lithium-ionen-batterien umweltgerecht zu
entsorgen und der kreislaufwirtschaft
zuzuführen die retouren vernichtung
werden wir reduzieren mit einem
gesetzlich verankerten vormodell
belohnen wir ressourcen schonendes und
recycling freundliches verpackungsdesign
sowie den rezyklat einsatz wir führen
ein recycling label ein mit einer
beschleunigung der entwicklung von
qualitätsstandards für rezyklate werden
neue hochwertige stoffkreisläufe
geschaffen
qualitätsgesicherter abfallprodukte
sollen aus dem abfallrecht entlassen
werden und ein produkt status erlangen
wir schreiben höhere recyclingquoten und
eine produkt psychische mindestquote für
den einsatz von rezyklaten und
sekundärrohstoffen auf europäischer
ebene fest wir nehmen chemisches
recycling im verpackungs gesetz als
recycling option auf
wir setzen uns für eine europaweite ende
der deponierung von siedlungsabfällen
1 wir gehen mit den ländern entschlossen
gegen illegale abfälle vor
der export von abfällen soll
europarechtlich nur noch in
zertifizierten recyclinganlagen möglich
sein wir wollen ein level playing field
für plastik rezyklate
[Applaus]
landwirtschaft und ernährung
eine nachhaltige landwirtschaft dient
zugleich den interessen der betriebe des
tirols und der natur und ist grundlage
einer gesunden ernährung tierschutz wir
führen ab 2022
eine verbindliche tierhaltung scan
zeichen um ein die auch transport und
schlachtung umfasst unser ziel sind
entsprechende verbindliche eu weit
einheitliche standards zudem führen wir
eine umfassende herkunftskennzeichnung
ein wir begleiten die einführung mit
einer informations und
aufklärungskampagne wir wollen die
landwirte dabei unterstützen die
nutztierhaltung in deutschland art
gerecht umzubauen
dafür streben wir an ein durch
marktteilnehmer getragenes finanzielles
system zu entwickeln
mit dessen einnahmen zweckgebunden die
laufenden kosten landwirtschaftlicher
betriebe ausgeglichen und investitionen
gefördert werden ohne den handel
bürokratisch zu belasten die
investitionsförderung wird künftig nach
den haltungs kriterien ausgerichtet und
in der regel nur nach den oberen stufen
gewährt das bau- und genehmigungsrecht
ist entsprechend anzupassen die
entwicklung der tierbestände soll sich
an der fläche orientieren und wird in
einklang mit den zielen des klima
gewässer und immissionsschutzes ammoniak
methan gebracht wir wollen die
emissionen aus ammoniak und methan unter
berücksichtigung das tierwohl es
deutlich mindern die landwirte sollen
auf dem weg zur klimaneutralität im
rahmen des umbaus denn und
nutztierhaltung unterstützt werden
wir streben an
planungs und investitionssicherheit
herzustellen wir führen ein prüf und
zulassungsverfahren für steuersysteme
und für serienmäßig hergestellte
betäubungs anlagen
wir verbessern die rechtsvorschriften
zum schutz vor bränden und technischen
störungen in ställen unter
berücksichtigung von angemessenen
übergangsfristen wir schließen
bestehende lücken in der
nutztierhaltungsverordnung
und verbessern das tierschutzgesetz
gesetz qualzucht
konkretisieren
nicht kurative eingriffe deutlich
reduzieren
anbindehaltung spätestens in zehn jahren
beenden
wir erarbeiten eine tier
gesundheitsstrategie und etablieren eine
umfassende datenbank
inklusive verarbeitungsbetriebe
tierischer nebenprodukte
wir werden den wirkstoff und
anwendungsbezogenen antibiotika einsatz
in landwirtschaftlichen betrieben
erfassen und senken
lebend tiertransporte in drittstaaten
werden künftig nur erlaubt wenn sie auf
routen mit nachgewiesen
tierschutzgerechten
versorgungseinrichtungen stattfinden
wir setzen uns auch auf eu ebene für
bessere regelungen für tiertransporte
und ein ausbau des datenbanksystems
traces 1 wir fördern die zentrale und
mobile schlacht schlacht strukturen
wir schaffen sie schaffen die
rechtsgrundlage zur einführung eines
standardisierten
kameragestützten überwachungssystems in
besonders tierschutzrelevanten bereichen
in schlachthöfen ab einer relevanten
größe
wir schließen rechts und vollzugs lücken
im bereich des tierschutzes um der
verantwortung aus der ausschließlich dem
start zustehenden eingriffs kompetenz
gerecht zu werden wir überführen teile
des tierschutz rechts in das strafrecht
und erhöhen das maximale strafmass wir
legen eine reduktion strategie zu
tierversuchen vor
wir verstärken die forschung zu
alternativen ihre umsetzung in die
praxis und etablieren ressort
übergreifendes
kompetenznetzwerk
wir führen für den online handel mit
heimtieren eine verpflichtende
identitätsüberprüfung 1
die kennzeichnung und registrierung von
hunden werden obligatorisch
wir aktualisieren die leitlinien für
tierbörsen und erarbeiten eine
positivliste für wildtiere die nach
einer übergangsfrist noch in zirkussen
gehalten werden können die
bildungsarbeit so logischer gärten
werden wir unterstützen tierheime werden
wir durch eine verbrauchs stiftung
unterstützen wir setzen uns für ein
eu-weites verbot der haltung und zucht
von pelztieren 1 der bund nimmt in
länderübergreifenden krisen und solchen
fällen wie der afrikanischen
schweinepest
eine koordinierende und unterstützende
funktion wahr und beseitigt rechtliche
mängel
wir schaffen das amt einer oder eines
tierschutzbeauftragten
europäische agrarpolitik
wir sorgen unverzüglich dafür dass die
begleit verordnungen zum nationalen
strategieplan der gemeinsamen
agrarpolitik gap
mit dem ziel des umwelt und
klimaschutzes sowie der
einkommenssicherung angepasst werden die
aktuelle architektur wird spätestens zur
mitte der legislaturperiode überprüft
und im sinne der zielerreichung
angepasst für die verlässliche
weiterentwicklung ab 2027
legt die bundesregierung mit dieser
evaluierung ein konzept vor wie die
direktzahlungen durch die honorierung
von klima und umwelt leistungen
angemessen ersetzt werden können
dies dient auch der einkommens-
wirksamkeit
gemeinschaftsaufgabe verbesserung der
agrarstruktur
und küstenschutz gak
orientiert andere formen der grw werden
wir die gemeinschaftsaufgabe neu an
unseren zielen ausrichten und setzen uns
für eine über jährige und flexible
finanzierung ein neue aufgaben wie
naturschutz und klima anpassen
müssen durch zusätzliche finanzmittel
gesichert werden kooperationen zwischen
naturschutz und landwirtschaft sollen
für die landwirtschaftliche förderung
eine rechtliche grundlage erhalten
ernährung
wir werden insbesondere mit blick auf
kinder mit den akteuren bis 2023 eine
ernährungs strategie beschließen
um eine gesunde umgebung für ernährung
und bewegung zu schaffen
wir werden die standards der deutschen
gesellschaft für ernährung aktualisieren
in der gemeinschaftsverpflegung als
standard etablieren
vernetzungsstellen weiter betreiben und
modellregionen wettbewerb durchführen
unser ziel ist den anteil regionaler und
ökologische erzeugnisse entsprechend
unsere ausbauziele zu erhöhen wir werden
gemeinsam mit allen beteiligten die
lebensmittelverschwendung verbindlich
branchenspezifisch reduzieren
haftungsrechtliche fragen klären und
steuerrechtliche erleichterungen für
spenden ermöglichen wir stärken
pflanzliche alternativen und setzen uns
für die zulassung von innovationen wie
alternative proteinquellen und fleisch
ersatzprodukten in der eu ein an kinder
gerichtete werbung für lebensmittel mit
hohem zucker- fett- und salzgehalt
darf es in zukunft bei sendungen und
formaten für unter 14 jährige nicht mehr
geben
wir werden ein eu-weites nu disco
wissenschaftlich und
allgemeinverständlich weiterentwickeln
wir unterstützen die entwicklung von
kriterien für einen ökologischen
fußabdruck wir werden den
gesundheitlichen verbraucherschutz
stärken
und zu gesundheitsgefährdenden stoffen
wie endokrine disruptoren
mehrfachbelastungen kontakt materialien
forschen kontakt materialen forschen
lebensmittelwarnung de wird praktikabler
weiterentwickelt
wir schaffen wissenschaftlich fundierte
und auf zielgruppen abgestimmte
reduktionsziele für zucker fett und salz
landbau das artensterben der verlust der
biodiversität ist eine weitere
ökologische krise wir wollen den einsatz
von pflanzenschutzmitteln auf das
notwendige maß beschränken mit folgenden
maßnahmen wollen wir den einsatz
ambitioniert reduzieren wir werden die
gesamte landwirtschaft in ihrer vielfalt
an den zielen umwelt und
ressourcenschutz ausrichten ökologischer
landbau wir wollen eine landwirtschaft
im einklang von natur und umwelt weiter
entwickeln hier wollen 30 prozent öko
landbau bis zum jahr 2030 erreichen
hierfür wollen wir die bundesmittel für
das bundesprogramm ökolandbau erhöhen
und entsprechend dem ausbauziel agrar
forschungsgelder für forschungs belange
des ökolandbaus zur verfügung stellen
wir erweitern die zukunftsstrategie
ökologische landbau um die gesamte bio
wertschöpfungskette der integrierte
pflanzenschutz wird ergänzt wir stärken
seine forschung und förderung und
entwickeln den nationalen aktionsplan
weiter
pflanzen sollen so geschützt werden
dass nebenwirkungen für umwelt
gesundheit und biodiversität vermieden
werden die zulassung von
pflanzenschutzmitteln muss transparent
und rechtssicher nach wissenschaftlichen
kriterien erfolgen
bestehende lücken auf europäischer ebene
werden geschlossen gleichzeitig muss
eine schnellere entscheidung stattfinden
zudem sorgen wir für eine verbesserung
der verfügbarkeit von
pflanzenschutzmitteln
insbesondere für anwendungen von
geringfügig geringfügigem umfang bei
vielfältig angebauten sonderkulturen für
den vorrat schutz und für geeignete
resistenz strategien wir setzen auch auf
digitale anwendungen und moderne
applikationstechnik zur zielgenauen
ausbringung und vermeidung von abdrift
die stärken alternativen zu
chemisch-synthetischen
pflanzenschutzmitteln
biologicals loris
pflanzenstärkungsmittel
physikalische biologische anbaumethoden
robotik drohnen die digitalisierung
prognosemodelle et cetera und verbessern
die zugehörigen verfahren analog zu
bestehenden regelungen zur pestiziden
den naturschutzgebieten bei den
landwirtinnen und landwirten ein
erschwernis ausgleich bekommen wollen
wir regeln für die trinkwasser
schutzgebiete finden wir nehmen
glyphosat bis ende 2003 und 20 vom markt
ein digitales herkunfts- und
identifikationssystem
nährstoff und pflanzenschutz mit dem
ziel die reduktion strategie voran zu
bringen soll eingeführt werden
die züchtung von klima robusten
pflanzensorten wollen wir unterstützen
dazu verbessern wir die
rahmenbedingungen auch für population
sorten fördern modellprojekte wie kraut
breeding
digitalisierung stellen transparenz über
züchtungsmethoden her und stärken die
risiko und nachweis forschung
digitalisierung in der landwirtschaft
wir werden die von der landwirtschaft
und ernährung benötigten öffentlichen
daten einfacher und in geeigneter
qualität und aktualität den berechtigten
nutzern frei zur verfügung stellen und
dazu eine echte plattform zentralen
zugang zu sämtlichen staatlichen daten
und diensten einrichten insbesondere
auch für entsprechende
verwaltungsdienstleistungen
staatliche daten aller verwaltungsebenen
sollen künftig in einheitlichen formaten
zur verfügung gestellt werden der agrar
datenraum in garics als basis einer
europäischen daten infrastruktur mit
klaren nutzungsrecht für landwirte an
den betriebsspezifischen daten an deren
entstehung sie mitgewirkt haben wird mit
standardisierten schnittstellen
weiterentwickelt open source formate
werden ausdrücklich unterstützt
bodenpolitik
die debatte der eu kommission über die
kabel certification guidelines begleiten
wir aktiv wir brauchen eine
aktualisierung des bodenschutz gesetzes
ein boden monitorings zentrum wir müssen
die eu bei einer boden richtlinie
unterstützen wir verstärken forschung
und förderung zu klima robust im
pflanzenbau sie startet hierfür ein
bundesprogramm zukunftsfähiger ackerbau
die eiweißpflanzen strategie entwickeln
wir weiter
die bvvg flächen werden für ausgleichs-
und ersatzmaßnahmen
haben sowie klima- und artenschutz
genutzt dabei werden landwirtschaftlich
genutzte flächen vorrangig an nachhaltig
bzw ökologisch wirtschaftende betriebe
verpachtet und nicht
veräußert
fischerei
wir setzen uns für den erhalt der
fischerei an unseren küsten ein wir
werden auf europäischer und
internationaler ebene eine faire
wissenschaftsbasierte ermittlung und
zuteilung der fangquoten einfordern
dazu werden wir eine zukunftskommission
fischerei initiieren um empfehlungen für
eine nachhaltige fischerei und
aquakultur binnen und hochseefischerei
zu erarbeiten
wir wollen die grundschleppnetzfischerei
beschränken und fangtechniken arten
spezifisch anpassen sowie eine
naturschutzgerechte
regulierung von stahl stellnetzen wir
erkennen die leistung der anderen und
angler für den natur und artenschutz an
lebensmittelmarkt hier unterstützen
fairen wettbewerb mit fairen preisen im
lebensmittelmarkt
wir werden die kartellrechtliche
missbrauchsaufsicht und
fusionskontrolle im bundeskartellamt
stärken wir gehen gegen unfaire
handelspraktiken vor und prüfen ob der
verkauf von lebensmitteln unter
produktionskosten unterbunden werden
kann
den milchmarkt werden wir weiter
beobachten und die bilanz der
lieferbeziehungen evaluieren
[Musik]
ein moment bitte
mobilität
wir wollen die 2020er jahre zu einem
aufbruch in der mobilitätspolitik nutzen
und eine nachhaltige effiziente
barrierefreie intelligente innovative
und für alle bezahlbare mobilität
ermöglichen für die notwendigen
veränderungsprozesse werben wir um
akzeptanz und werden unsere ziele dialog
orientiert umsetzen und die maßnahmen
regelmäßig überprüfen
die erforderlichen entscheidungen zur
erreichung unserer klimaschutzziele für
2030 und 2045 mit dem ziel der
dekarbonisierung des mobilitäts
bereiches denn wir treffen und die
praktische umsetzung deutlich
beschleunigen mobilität ist für uns ein
zentraler baustein der daseinsvorsorge
voraussetzung für gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse und die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit des wirtschafts und
logistikstandort deutschland mit
zukunftsfesten arbeitsplätzen dafür
werden wir infrastruktur ausbauen und
modernisieren sowie rahmenbedingungen
für vielfältige mobilitätsangebote in
stadt und land weiterentwickeln
infrastruktur die investitionen in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur
müssen weiter erhöht und langfristig
abgesichert werden dabei wollen wir
erheblich mehr in die schiene als in die
straße investieren um prioritär projekte
eines deutschlandpaktes umzusetzen bei
den bundesfernstraßen wollen wir einen
stärkeren fokus auf erhalt und sanierung
legen mit besonderem schwerpunkt auf
ingenieurbauwerke dazu werden wir den
anteil der erhaltungs mittel bis 2025
bei wachsendem etat schrittweise erhöhen
wir streben einen neuen infrastruktur
konsens bei den bundesverkehrswege nan
dazu werden wir parallel zur laufenden
bedarfsplan überprüfung ein dialog
prozess mit verkehrs umwelt wirtschafts
und verbraucherschutzverbänden staaten
mit dem ziel einer verständigung über
die prioritäten bei der umsetzung des
geltenden
bundesverkehrswegeplan bis zur
bedarfsplan überprüfung gibt es eine
gemeinsame abstimmung über die laufenden
projekte werden
auf basis neuer kriterien einen neuen
bundesverkehrswege und mobilitäts plan
2040 auf den weg bringen wir wollen das
nebeneinander von autobahn gmbh und
deutsche einheit fernstraßenplanungs und
bau gesellschaft dig s de ge es aufheben
zwischen bund und autobahn gmbh wollen
wir eine über jährige
finanzierungsvereinbarung abschließen
wir werden 2023 eine co2 differenzierung
der lkw-maut vornehmen den gewerblichen
güterkraftverkehr ab 3,5 tonnen
einbeziehen und einen co2 zuschlag
einführen unter der bedingung eine
doppelbelastung durch den co2 preis
auszuschließen wir werden die
mehreinnahmen für mobilität einsetzen
wir wollen lärmbelästigungen durch den
verkehr reduzieren setzen uns für eine
reduzierung von mutwilligen lärm ein und
sorgen für mehr aktiven und passiven
lärmschutz um zu angemessenen lärmschutz
maßnahmen zukommen werden wir die
gesamte lärmsituation berücksichtigen
die lärm sanierungsprogramme für
bundesfernstraßen und schienenwege wenn
wir besser finanzieren innovative
technik zur lärmvermeidung so für neue
güterwagen werden wir bis zur
markteinführung unterstützen
bahnverkehr
wir werden den masterplan
schienenverkehr weiter entwickeln und
zügig umsetzen
den schienengüterverkehr bis 2030 auf 25
prozent steigern und die
verkehrsleistung im personenverkehr
verdoppeln den ziel fahrplan eines
deutschlandpaktes und die infrastruktur
kapazität werden wir auf diese ziele
ausrichten sofern haushalterisch machbar
soll die nutzung der schiene günstiger
werden um die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
bahnen zu stärken wir werden mehr
oberzentren an den fernverkehr anbinden
wir werden die umsetzung eines
deutschlandtag des infrastrukturell
finanziell organisatorisch eisenbahn
rechtlich und europarechtskonform
absichern
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr wollen wir
stärken
und mit der eu sowie ihren
mitgliedsstaaten nachtzug angebote
aufbauen bis 2030 wollen wir 75 prozent
schienennetzes elektr offizieren
und innovative antriebstechnologien
unterstützen die digitalisierung von
fahrzeugen und strecken werden wir
prioritär vorantreiben
wir werden ein programm schnelle
kapazitätserweiterung auflegen
barrierefreiheit und lärmschutz
verbessern bahnhofs programme bündeln
und starten das streckennetz erweitern
strecken reaktivieren und stilllegungen
vermeiden und eine beschleunigungs
kommission china einsetzen die
einführung der digitalen automatischen
kupplung wollen wir beschleunigen den
einzelwagenverkehr stärken und
investitionsanreize für gleisanschlüsse
setzen bei neuen gewerbe- und
industriegebieten soll die
schienenanbindung verpflichtend geprüft
werden
kv terminals wollen wir weiter fördern
die kran barkeit von standard
sattelaufliegern vorantreiben und den
zu- und ablauf bis maximal 50 kilometer
von der lkw-maut freistellen
wir werden die deutsche bahn ag als
integrierten konzern inklusive des
konzerninternen arbeitsmarktes im
öffentlichen eigentum erhalten
die internen strukturen werden wir
effizienter und transparenter gestalten
die infrastruktur einheiten db netz db
station & service der deutschen bahn ag
werden innerhalb des konzerns zu einer
neuen
gemeinwohlorientierten
infrastruktursparte zusammengelegt diese
steht zu 100 prozent im eigentum der
deutschen bahn als gesamtkonzern gewinne
aus dem betrieb der infrastruktur
verbleiben zukünftig in der neuen
infrastruktur einheit die
eisenbahnverkehrsunternehmen werden
markt und
gewinnorientiert im wettbewerb weiter
geführt
wir wollen die investitionsmittel für
die db infrastruktur erhöhen
öffentlicher verkehr und neue
mobilitätsangebote wir wollen länder und
kommunen in die lage versetzen
attraktivität und kapazitäten spnv zu
verbessern ziel ist die fahrgastzahl
allen des öffentlichen verkehrs deutlich
zu steigern
2022 werden wir die pandemie bedingten
einnahmeausfälle wie bisher ausgleichen
wir wollen ein ausbau und modernisierung
pakt bei dem sich bund länder und
kommunen unter anderem über die
finanzierung bis 2030
einschließlich der eigenanteile der
länder und kommunen und die aufteilung
der bundesmittel verständigen sowie
tarifstrukturen diskutieren
regionalisierungsmittel werden ab 2022
erhöht gemeinsam werden wir
qualitätskriterien und standards für
angebote und erreichbarkeit für urbane
und ländliche räume definieren für eine
nahtlose mobilität verpflichten wir
verkehrsunternehmen und
mobilitätsanbieter ihre echtzeitdaten
unter fairen bedingungen bereitzustellen
anbieterübergreifende digitale buchung
und bezahlung wollen wir ermöglichen den
datenraum mobilität entwickeln wir
weiter
intermodale verknüpfungen werden wir
stärken und barrierefreie mobilität
station fördern
digitale mobilitätsdienste innovative
mobilitätslösungen und carsharing werden
werden wir unterstützen und in eine
langfristige strategie für autonomes und
vernetztes fahren öffentlicher verkehr
einbeziehen damit alle neuen busse
einschließlich der infrastrukturen
möglichst zeitnah klimaneutral fahren
wird der bund die bestehende förderung
verlängern und mittelstandsfreundlicher
durchaus gestalten wir setzen uns für
faire arbeitsbedingungen im öpnv ein zu
diesem zweck stärken wir die tariftreue
und schaffen die gesetzliche grundlage
dafür
tarifverträge zur bedingung bei
ausschreibungen zu machen
mittelständische interessen sind bei der
vergabe zu berücksichtigen am vorrang
eigenwirtschaftliche verkehre halten wir
fest
mobilitätsforschung werden wir
interdisziplinär
aufwerten das zentrum zukunft der
mobilität neu aufstellen und erweitern
sowie das zentrum für schienenverkehrs
forschung stärken
güterverkehr
wir unterstützen regionale güterverkehrs
konzepte fördern emissionsfreie stadt
logistik wie lade sohn & logistik
hoops
die genehmigungspraxis von schwerlast
und grob groß großraum transporten
wollen wir erleichtern die
kontrollbehörden werden wir stärken und
bessere sozialstandards und
arbeitsbedingungen durchsetzen
sichere lkw stellflächen an und um
autobahnen werden wir ausbauen und
thematisch optimieren wir werden dem
fachkräftemangel entgegenwirken
qualifizierung modernisieren und
bürokratie abbauen
autoverkehr
wir werden den
transformationsprozess der deutschen
automobilindustrie vor dem hintergrund
von digitalisierung und dekarbonisierung
unterstützen rahmenbedingungen und
fördermaßnahmen werden wir darauf
ausrichten dass deutschland leitmarkt
für elektromobilität mit mindestens 15
millionen elektro pkw im jahr 2030 ist
gemäss den vorschlägen vorschlägen der
europäischen kommission werden im
verkehrsbereich in europa 2035 nur noch
co2 neutrale fahrzeuge zugelassen
entsprechend früher wirkt sich dies in
deutschland außerhalb des bestehenden
systems der flotten grenzwerte setzen
uns dafür ein dass nachweisbar nur mit
fuel tank bahre fahrzeuge neu zugelassen
werden können wir setzen uns für die
verabschiedung einer ambitionierten und
umsetzbaren schadstoffnorm euro 7 1 und
werden dabei wertschöpfung und
arbeitsplätze berücksichtigen
der ausbau der ladeinfrastruktur muss
den bedarf vorausgehen
wir werden deshalb den voraus laufenden
ausbau der ladesäulen infrastruktur mit
dem ziel von einer million öffentlich
und diskriminierungsfrei zugänglichen
ladepunkten bis 2030 mit schwerpunkt auf
schnell ladeinfrastruktur ressort
übergreifend beschleunigen auf effizienz
überprüfen und entbürokratisieren wir
setzen auf die mobilisierung privater
investitionen
wo wettbewerbliche lösungen nicht
greifen werden wir mit versorgungs
auflagen wo baulich möglich die
verlässliche erreichbarkeit von laden
herstellen wir werden die förderung für
den ausbau der ladeinfrastruktur
effektiver und effizienter ausgestaltet
wir werden hemmnisse in
genehmigungsprozessen bei der
netzinfrastruktur und den netzanschluss
bedingungen abbauen und die kommunen bei
einer vorausschauenden planung der
ladeinfrastruktur unterstützen wir
werden
bidirektionales laden ermöglichen
wir sorgen für transparente strompreise
und einen öffentlich einsehbaren
belegung status wir werden den aufbau
eines flächendeckenden netzes an
schnelllade hoops habs beschleunigen und
die anzahl der ausgeschriebenen hoops
erhöhen wir werden den masterplan
ladeinfrastruktur zügig überarbeiten und
darin notwendige maßnahmen aus den
bereichen bau energie und verkehr binden
sowie ein schwerpunkt auf kommunale
vernetzung der lösung legen wir setzen
uns für ambitionierte ausbauziele auf
europäischer ebene ein gesetz für eine
weiterentwicklung der co2 flotten
grenzwerte für nutzfahrzeuge ein und
unterstützen die vorschläge der
europäischen kommission für den aufbau
von tank und ladeinfrastruktur für lkw
wir schaffen ein mobilitäts daten gesetz
und stellen freie zugänglichkeit von
verkehrsdaten sicher zur
wettbewerbsneutralen nutzung von
fahrzeugdaten streben wir ein
treuhändermodell an das zugriffs
bedürfnisse der nutzer private anbieter
und staatlicher organe sowie die
interessen betroffener unternehmen und
entwickler angemessen berücksichtigt im
gesetz zum autonomen fahren werden wir
die regelung verbessern haftungsfragen
klären und die datenhoheit der nutzer
sicher stellen
verkehrs ordnung
wir werden straßenverkehrsgesetz und
straßenverkehrsordnung so anpassen dass
neben der flüssigkeit und sicherheit des
verkehrs die ziele des klima und
umweltschutzes
der gesundheit und der städtebaulichen
entwicklung berücksichtigt werden um
ländern und kommunen entscheidungs
spielräume zu eröffnen wir wollen eine
öffnung für digitale anwendungen wie
digitale parkraum kontrolle in umsetzung
der vision zero werden wir das
verkehrssicherheitsprogramm
weiterentwickeln ein generelles
tempolimit wird es nicht geben
um jugendliche schon frühzeitig für die
gefahren im straßenverkehr zu schulen
werden wir begleitetes fahren ab 16
möglichen wir wollen mehr digitale
elemente des führerschein unterrichts
ermöglichen die digitalisierung von
fahrzeug dokumenten vorantreiben und das
monopol bei der fahrerlaubnisprüfung
unter wahrung geltender
qualitätsstandards aufheben
wir wollen dass notbrems und abstands
assistenten in nutzfahrzeugen nicht
abgeschaltet werden dürfen die
nachrüstung von lkw abbiege
assistenzsystemen werden wir bis zum
verpflichtenden einbau weiterhin fördern
radverkehr wir werden den nationalen
radverkehrsplan umsetzen und
fortschreiben den ausbau und die
modernisierung des radwegenetzes sowie
die förderung kommunaler radverkehrs
infrastruktur vorantreiben zur stärkung
des radverkehrs wenn wir die mittel bis
2030 absichern und die kombination von
rad und öffentlichen verkehr fördern den
fußverkehr werden wir strukturell
unterstützen und mit einer nationalen
strategie unterlegen
schiffsverkehr wir werden eine nationale
hafen strategie entwickeln und die enge
zusammenarbeit unsere häfen fördern der
bund steht zur gemeinsamen verantwortung
für die notwendigen hafen
infrastrukturen den schifffahrts anteil
im güterverkehr wollen wir steigern und
dazu auch hinterlandanbindungen stärken
wir werden landstrom und alternative
antriebe und kraftstoffe fördern wir
werden das flotten erneuerungsprogramm
für die klimafreundliche
binnenschifffahrt anpassen wir wollen
bei der ausgestaltung von fit for fifty
five die gesamtbelastungen für die
schifffahrt im blick behalten
das bundesamt für seeschifffahrt und
hydrographie werden wir stärken um eine
einheitliche flaggen staatsverwaltung
einzuführen und um den offshore
windenergie ausbau zu beschleunigen
wir werden sanierung und ausbau von
schleusen beschleunigen wir werden einen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen dialog zu klima
resilienz und naturschutz bei
wasserstraßen initiieren wir werden die
wasserstraßen und schifffahrtsverwaltung
stärken und ihre effizienz erhöhen
luftverkehr
wir wollen die deutsche
luftverkehrswirtschaft und industrie als
schlüsselbranchen nachhaltig und
leistungsfähig weiterentwickeln in einem
umfassenden beteiligungsprozess ein luft
verkehrskonzept 2030 plus zur zukunft
der flughäfen in deutschland erstellen
die schienenanbindung von drehkreuzen
fördern und durch bessere
bahnverbindungen die anzahl von
kurzstreckenflügen verringern
deutschland soll vorreiter beim co2
neutralen fliegen werden bei wahrung von
fairen rahmenbedingungen im
internationalen wettbewerb
unser ziel ist die schaffung von fairen
rahmenbedingungen im internationalen
wettbewerb für einen wirksamen
klimaschutz im luftverkehr
der emission effektiv reduziert sowie
haben lipitsch vermeidet bis zur
europäischen entscheidung über die
einführung einer kerosinsteuer
in anlehnung an den energie gab an den
eine energiegehalt werden wir uns dafür
einsetzen auch europaweit eine
luftverkehrsabgabe einzuführen wie sie
in deutschland erhoben wird wir werden
uns bei der europäischen union dafür
einsetzen dass flugtickets nicht zu
einem preis unterhalb der steuern
zuschläge entgelte und gebühren verkauft
werden dürfen mit blick auf die aktuelle
pandemie bedingte krise der
luftfahrtbranche werden wir eine
erhöhung der luftverkehrs abgabe erst
nach 2023 prüfen
einnahmen aus der luftverkehrssteuer
werden wir für die förderung von
produktion und einsatz von co2 neutralen
strom basierten flugkraftstoffen sowie
für forschung entwicklung und
flottenmodernisierung
im luftverkehr einsetzen wir
unterstützen ambitionierte quoten für
power to liquid btl quoten im luft und
schiffsverkehr um ein markthochlauf
anzureizen
wir wollen fluglärm reduzieren und den
anteil lärmabhängige flughafen entgelte
erhöht wir fördern einen klimaneutralen
flughafenbetrieb
die aufgabe der deutschen flugsicherung
wird um das thema eines effektiven
lärmschutzes erweitert eine änderung des
fluglärmschutz gesetzes werden wir auf
basis des evaluierungsberichts der
bundesregierung betrachten wir werden
uns auf eu ebene für die umsetzung des
single european sky und einen
niedrigeren schwefelgehalt von kerosin
einsetzen detektion und abwehr von
drohnen ist hoheitliche aufgabe
klima energie
transformation
der menschengemachte klimawandel
ist eine der größten herausforderungen
unserer zeit wir müssen die klimakrise
gemeinsam bewältigen darin liegen auch
große chancen für die modernisierung
unseres landes und den industriestandort
deutschland
neue geschäftsmodelle und technologien
können klimaneutralen wohlstand und gute
arbeit schaffen die neue bundesregierung
wird den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien zu einem zentralen projekt
ihrer regierungsarbeit machen wir werden
national in europa und international
unsere klima energie und
wirtschaftspolitik auf den 1,5 grad pfad
ausrichten und die potenziale auf allen
staatlichen ebenen aktivieren um dies zu
erreichen werden wir unsere ziele
ambitioniert aus dem gemeinsamen beitrag
ableiten zu dem sich die europäische
union im rahmen des pariser abkommens
verpflichtet hat dabei sichern wir die
freiheit kommender generationen im sinne
der entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts in dem wir
einen verlässlichen und
kosteneffizienten weg zur
klimaneutralität
spätestens
2045 technologieoffen ausgestalten am
deutschen atomausstieg halten wir fest
wir setzen auf eine sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft und auf konkrete
maßnahmen die in den nächsten jahren
umgesetzt werden und die menschen
mitnehmen in den verhandlungen über das
eu programm
f unterstützen wir die vorschläge der
eu-kommission und wollen in den
einzelnen sektoren die instrumente
möglichst technologieneutral
ausgestalten
klimaschutzgesetz
wir werden das klimaschutzgesetz noch im
jahr 2022 konsequent weiterentwickeln
und ein klimaschutz sofortprogramm mit
allen notwendigen gesetzen verordnungen
und maßnahmen auf den weg bringen wir
werden klimaschutz zu einer
querschnittsaufgabe
machen indem das jeweils federführende
ressort seine gesetzentwürfe auf ihre
klimawirkung und die vereinbarkeit mit
den nationalen klimaschutzzielen hin
prüft und bin einer entsprechenden
begründung versieht klima check alle
sektoren werden einen beitrag leisten
müssen verkehr bauen und wohnen
stromerzeugung industrie und
landwirtschaft die einhaltung der
klimaziele werden wir anhand einer
sektorübergreifenden und analog zum
pariser klimaabkommen mehrjährigen
gesamtrechnung überprüfen basis dafür
ist das jährliche monitoring auf dem weg
zur klimaneutralität müssen alle
sektoren ihren beitrag zum erreichen der
klimaziele leisten
wir wollen mit aller kraft vermeiden
dass deutschland aufgrund einer nicht
erreichung seiner klimaziele eu
emissionshandels zertifikate im rahmen
der eu lastenteilung kaufen muss die den
bundeshaushalt belasten
wir werden ein klimaschutz
sofortprogramm mit allen notwendigen
gesetzen und vorhaben bis ende 2022 auf
den weg bringen und abschließen
erneuerbare energien wir machen es zu
unserer gemeinsamen mission den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien drastisch zu
beschleunigen und alle hürden und
hemmnisse aus dem weg zu räumen wir
richten unser erneuerbaren ziel auf
einen höheren brutto strombedarf von 680
bis 750 twh im jahr 2030 aus davon
sollen 80 prozent aus erneuerbaren
energien stammen entsprechend
beschleunigen wir den netzausbau die
jährlichen ausschreibungs mengen
passende dynamisch an wir benötigen
einen instrumenten mix um den massiven
ausbau zu erreichen neben dem eeg werden
wir in argumente für den voerder freien
super wie zb langfristige
stromlieferverträge ppa und den
europaweiten handel mit
herkunftsnachweisen im sinne des
klimaschutzes stärken den dezentralen
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien wollen
wir stärken erneuerbarer strom
insbesondere aus aus geförderten anlagen
und anlagen außerhalb der eeg förderung
soll stärker in der erzeuger region
genutzt werden können dafür werden wir
alle notwendigen regelungen überprüfen
grün erzeugter strom muss in der
erzeuger region auch als grüner strom
genutzt werden dürfen wir werden
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
erheblich beschleunigen die erneuerbaren
energien liegen im öffentlichen
interesse und dienen der versorgung
versorgungssicherheit bei der schutz
güterabwägung setzen uns dafür ein dass
es ein zeitlich bis zum erreichen der
klimaneutralität befristeten vorrang für
erneuerbare energien gibt es schaffen
rechtssicherheit im artenschutzrecht
unter anderem durch die anwendung einer
bundeseinheitlichen bewertungsmethode
bei der artenschutz prüfung von
windenergie vorhaben des weiteren werden
wir uns für eine stärkere ausrichtung
auf den population schutz auf
europäischer ebene einsetzen und die
ausnahmetatbestände rechtssicher fassen
wir setzen uns dafür ein dass die
zulassungsbehörden durch den einsatz
externer projektteams wirksam entlastet
werden der zeitliche beginn der
gesetzlichen genehmigungs fristen soll
durch klare anforderungen an die
antragsunterlagen gesichert werden auch
soll eine klarstellung der
umsetzungsfristen für genehmigungen
vorgenommen werden alle geeigneten
dachflächen sollen künftig für die
solarenergie genutzt werden bei
gewerblichen neubauten soll dies
verpflichtend bei privaten neubauten
soll es die regel werden bürokratische
hürden werden wir abbauen und wege
eröffnen und private bauherren
finanziell und akten das administrativ
nicht zu überfordern
wir sehen darin auch ein
konjunkturprogramm für mittelstand und
handwerk unser ziel für den ausbau der
photovoltaik pv sind ca 200 gw bis 2030
dazu beseitigen wir alle hemmnisse unter
anderem werden wir netzanschlüsse und
die zertifizierung beschleunigen
vergütungssätze anpassen die
ausschreibungspflicht für große
dachanlagen und die deckel prüfen auch
innovative energie wie agri und floating
pv werden wir stärken und die co nutzung
ermöglichen für die windenergie an land
sollen zwei prozent der landesflächen
ausgewiesen werden die nähere
ausgestaltung des flächen ziel verfolgt
dem baugesetzbuch wir stärken den bund
länder kooperations ausschuss wir werden
noch im ersten halbjahr
2022 entschuldigung
wir werden auch im ersten halbjahr 2022
gemeinsam mit bund ländern und kommunen
alle notwendigen maßnahmen anstoßen um
das gemeinsame ziel eines beschleunigten
erneuerbaren ausbaus und die
bereitstellung der dafür notwendigen
flächen zu organisieren wir werden
sicherstellen dass er ein weniger wind
heftigen
wind häufigen regionen der windenergie
ausbau deutlich voran kommt damit in
ganz deutschland auch verbrauchs na on
shore windenergie zur verfügung steht
und netzengpässe vermieden werden wo
bereits windparks stehen muss es ohne
großen genehmigungs aufwand möglich sein
alte in den windenergieanlagen durch
neue zu ersetzen den konflikt zwischen
windkraftausbau und artenschutz wollen
wir durch innovative technische
vermeidungs maßnahmen entschärfen unter
anderem durch anti kollisions systeme
wollen die abstände zu 3 funk feuern und
wetter radaren kurzfristig reduzieren
bei der ausweisung von ti flugkorridoren
soll der windenergie ausbau verstärkt
berücksichtigt werden
die kapazitäten für windenergie auf see
werden wir auf mindestens 30 gw 2030 40
gw 2035 und 70 gw
2045 erheblich steigern dazu werden wir
entsprechende flächen in der außen-
wirtschaftszone sichern offshore anlagen
sollen priorität gegenüber anderen
nutzungsformen genießen auch in der ko-
nutzung sehen wir eine möglichkeit für
einen besseren interessenausgleich
betreiben europäische offshore
kooperation weiter voran und sternen
grenzüberschreitende projekte mit nord-
und ostsee den zusätzlicher zeugten
offshore windstrom werden wir
beschleunigt eingriffs minimieren und
gebündelt anbinden die dafür notwendigen
technologie entscheidungen
beispielsweise zur rolle hybrider
interkonnektoren von mazda offshore
netze oder von multi terminal
anbindungen werden wir umgehend treffen
und dabei auch die landseitige
netzintegration im blick haben die
bioenergie in deutschland soll eine neue
zukunft haben dazu werden wir eine
nachhaltige biomasse strategie
erarbeiten
wir wollen das potenzial der geothermie
für die energieversorgung unter anderem
durch verbesserung der datenlage und
prüfung einer findigkeit
risikoversicherung stärker nutzen wir
wollen dafür sorgen dass kommunen von
windenergieanlagen und größe und
freiflächen solaranlagen auf ihrem
gebiet finanziell angemessen profitieren
können wir starten die bürger energie
als wichtiges element für mehr akzeptanz
im rahmen des europa rechtlich möglichen
werden wir die rahmenbedingungen für die
bürgerenergie verbessern energy sharing
prüfung eines fonds der die risiken
absichert und insgesamt die de minimis
regel regelungen als beitrag zum
bürokratieabbau
ausschöpfen wir werden im rahmen der
novellierung des steuer abgaben und
umlagen systems die förderung von mieter
strom und quartiers konzepten
vereinfachen und stärken wir werden uns
für eine flächendeckende kommunale wärme
planung und den ausbau der wärmenetze
einsetzen wir streben einen sehr hohen
anteil energie erneuerbare energien bei
der wärme an und wollen bis 2030 50
prozent der wärme klimaneutral
erzeugen wir werden die länder zu
gesprächen darüber einladen wie der bund
sie bei der umsetzung der in der
klimarahmenkonvention verankerten klima
bildung am besten unterstützen kann
kohleausstieg
zur einhaltung der klimaschutzziele ist
auch ein beschleunigter ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung nötig idealerweise
gelingt das schon bis 2030 die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das verschärft
2030 klimaziel sowie die kommende und
von uns unterstützte verschärfung des eu
emissionshandels schränken die
spielräume zunehmend ein das verlangt
den von uns angestrebten massiven ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien und die
errichtung moderner gaskraftwerke um den
im laufe der nächsten jahre steigenden
strom- und energiebedarf zu
wettbewerbsfähigen preisen zu decken
dafür werden wir den für 2026 im kohle
ausstiegs gesetz vorgesehenen
überprüfung schritt bis spätestens ende
2022 analog zum gesetz vornehmen die bis
zur versorgungssicherheit durch
erneuerbare energien notwendigen
gaskraftwerke
sollen zur nutzung der vorhandenen
netzinfrastrukturen und zur sicherung
von zukunftsperspektiven auch am
bisherigen
kraftwerksstandorten gebaut werden sie
müssen so gebaut werden dass sie auf
klimaneutrale gase h2 ready umgestellt
werden können die versorgungssicherheit
und den schnellen ausbau der
erneuerbaren werden wir regelmäßig
überprüfen dazu werden wir das
monitoring der versorgungssicherheit mit
strom und wärme zu einem echten
stresstest weiterentwickeln die
betroffenen regionen sowie die vom
kohleabbau betroffenen können weiterhin
auf solidarische unterstützung zählen
maßnahmen des struktur stärkung des
gesetzes wie zum beispiel das vorhaben
universitätsmedizin cottbus werden
vorgezogen beziehungsweise beschleunigt
die flankierenden arbeitspolitische
maßnahmen wie das anpassungs geld werden
entsprechend angepasst
und um eine qualifizierungs komponente
für jüngere beschäftigte ergänzt niemand
wird ins bergfreie fallen
unser ziel ist es im rahmen des kohle
ausstiegs ergänzend zu den bisher im
gesetz zugesagten leistungen an kommunen
keine zusätzlichen entschädigungen an
unternehmen zu zahlen die im dritten um
siedlungs- abschnitt betroffenen dörfer
im rheinischen revier wollen wir
erhalten über lutzerath werden die
gerichte entscheiden
geprüft wird die errichtung einer
stiftung oder gesellschaft die einen
rückbau der kohleverstromung und die
renaturierung
organisiert
gas und
wasserstoff eine energie
infrastruktur für erneuerbaren strom und
wasserstoff ist eine voraussetzung für
die europäische handlungsfähigkeit und
wettbewerbsfähigkeit im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wir wollen
die energieversorgung für deutschland
und europa
diversifizieren für energiepolitische
projekte auch in deutschland wird das
europäische energie recht wir
beschleunigen den massiven ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und die errichtung
moderner gaskraftwerke um den im laufe
der nächsten jahre steigenden strom- und
energiebedarf zu wettbewerbsfähigen
preisen zu decken die bis zur
versorgungssicherheit durch erneuerbare
energien notwendigen gas kraftwerke
müssen so gebaut werden dass sie auf
klimaneutrale gase h2 ready umgestellt
werden können erdgas ist für eine
übergangszeit
unverzichtbar die wasserstoff die
wasserstoff strategie wird 2022
fortgeschrieben ziel ist ein schneller
markthochlauf erste priorität hat die
einheimische erzeugung auf basis
erneuerbarer energien für einen
schnellen hochlauf und bis zu einer
günstigen versorgung mit grünem
wasserstoff setzen wir auf eine
technologieoffene ausgestaltung der
wasserstoff regulatorisch wir wollen den
aufbau einer leistungsfähigen
wasserstoffwirtschaft und die dafür
notwendige import und
transportinfrastruktur möglichst schnell
vorantreiben wir wollen eine elektrolyse
kapazität von rund 10 gigawatt im jahr
2030 erreichen dies werden wir unter
anderem durch den zubau von offshore
windenergie sowie
europas sicherstellen dazu ist ein
engagierter aufbau der notwendigen
infrastruktur erforderlich dafür werden
wir die notwendigen rahmenbedingungen
einschließlich effizient gestalteter
förderprogramme schaffen und
insbesondere auch die europäische
zusammenarbeit in diesem bereich stärken
wir werden die novellierte erneuerbare
energien richtlinie nach verabschiedung
möglichst technologieoffen und
ambitioniert umsetzen dabei schließen
wir atomkraft weiter hinaus beim import
von wasserstoff werden wir die
klimapolitischen auswirkungen beachten
und faire wettbewerbsbedingungen für
unsere wirtschaft sicherstellen wir
setzen uns auf europäischer ebene für
eine einheitliche
zertifizierung von wasserstoff und seine
folgeprodukte nein und stärken stärken
europäische import partnerschaften wir
werden das pci wasserstoff zusammen mit
den bundesländern schnell umsetzen und
investitionen in den aufbau einer
wasserstoff-infrastruktur fördern wir
wollen programme wie zum beispiel k2
global europäisch weiterentwickeln und
entsprechend finanziell ausstatten
netze
strom und wasserstoff netze sind das
rückgrat des energiesystems der zukunft
für den massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien brauchen wir mehr tempo und
verbindlichkeit beim netzausbau auf
allen ebenen
netzinfrastrukturen wollen wir in
zukunft auf allen politischen ebenen
stärker gemeinsam und vorausschauend
planen dazu werden wir
bundesnetzagentur und netzbetreiber
umgehend beauftragen einen über die
aktuellen netzentwicklungsplan ungen
hinausgehenden plan für ein
klimaneutralität netz zu berechnen und
den bundes bedarfsplan entsprechend
fortschreiben besonders augenmerk muss
bei allen maßnahmen auf den
stromautobahnen liegen im rahmen des
klimaschutz sofortprogramms werden wir
weitere maßnahmen auf den weg bringen
wir werden die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren für eine
schnellere planung und realisierung von
strom und wasserstoff netzen
beschleunigen wir gewährleisten eine
klare zuordnung der politischen
verantwortung für gute frühzeitige
bürgerbeteiligung beim netzausbau wir
legen bis mitte 2003 und 20 eine roadmap
systemstabilität vor wir werden die
verteilnetze modernisieren und
digitalisieren unter anderem durch eine
vorausschauende planung und mehr
steuerbarkeit den rollout intelligenter
messsysteme als voraussetzung für smart
grids werden wir unter gewährleistung
des datenschutzes und der it-sicherheit
erheblich beschleunigen wir werden
speicher als eigenständige säule des
energiesystems recht nicht definieren
die bereitstellung von kapital für die
netzinfrastruktur braucht im
europäischen vergleich auch zukünftig
attraktive investitionsbedingungen wir
werden im einklang mit europäischem
recht den staatlichen einfluss auf
kritische infrastruktur sicherstellen
wenn sich als interessen berührt sind
strommarkt design im zuge des ausbaus
der erneuerbaren energien werden da ein
neues strommarkt design erarbeiten dazu
setzen wir gemeinsam als bundesregierung
und koalitionsfraktionen eine plattform
klimaneutrales stromsystem 1 die 2022
konkrete vorschläge macht und
stakeholder aus wissenschaft wirtschaft
und zivilgesellschaft einbezieht dabei
bekennen wir uns zu einer weiteren
integration des europäischen
energiebinnenmarktes um den zügigen
ausbau zubau besicherter leistung
anzureizen und den atom und kohle
ausstieg abzusichern wenn wir in diesem
rahmen bestehende instrumente evaluieren
sowie wettbewerbliche und
technologieoffene kapazitäts mechanismen
und flexibilität prüfen dazu zählen
unter anderem gesicherte erneuerbaren
leistungen hocheffiziente gaskraftwerke
mit kraft wärme kopplung im rahmen der
weiterentwicklung des entsprechenden
gesetzes ein innovationsprogramm um h2
rallye gaskraftwerke auch am
kohlekraftwerk standorten anreizen zu
können speicher
energieeffizienzmaßnahmen und
lastmanagement wir werden marktpreise
bei der künftigen kwk förderung
angemessen berücksichtigen außerdem
bedarf es einer raschen und umfassenden
reform der finanzierungs architektur des
energiesystems der weg muss darin
bestehen
anreize für die sektorübergreifende
nutzung von erneuerbaren energien
dezentrale erzeugung modelle sowie die
vermeidung von treibhausgasemissionen
konsequent zu stärken wir gewährleisten
dass erneuerbarer strom wirtschaftlich
für die sektoren kopplung genutzt wird
anstatt die anlagen wegen netzengpässen
abzuschalten wir werden die staatlich
induzierten preisbestandteile im
energiesektor grundlegend reformieren
und dabei auf systematische
konsistente transparente und möglichst
verzerrungsfreie wettbewerbsbedingungen
abzielen sektoren kopplung ermöglichen
und so ein level playing field für alle
energieträger und sektoren schaffen
dabei spielt der co2 preis eine zentrale
rolle wir treiben eine reform entgelte
fordern die die transparenz stärkt die
transformation zur klimaneutralität
fördert und die kosten der integration
der erneuerbaren energien fair verteilt
sozial gerechte energiepreise
um auch angesichts höherer co2 preis
komponenten für sozial gerechte und für
die wirtschaft wettbewerbsfähige
energiepreise zu sorgen
werden wir die finanzierung der eeg
umlage über den strompreis
beenden wir werden sie daher zum ersten
januar 2023 in den haushalt übernehmen
die finanzierung übernimmt der wkf der
aus den einnahmen der
emissionshandelssysteme wie ihr hg und
ets und einem zuschuss aus dem
bundeshaushalt gespeist wird der etf
wird in der lage sein die finanzierung
der nötigen klimaschutzmaßnahmen und der
eeg umlage zu stemmen mit der vollendung
des kohle ausstiegs
werden wir die förderung der
erneuerbaren energien auslaufen lassen
im rahmen dieser änderungen werden alle
ausnahmen von eeg umlage und energie
steuern sowie die
kompensationsregeln überprüft und
angepasst ziel ist es
steuerbegünstigungen abzubauen die sich
auf die wirtschaftliche nutzung von
strom beziehen und dabei die entlastung
durch den wegfall der eeg umlage zu
berücksichtigen
die unternehmen sollen dadurch insgesamt
nicht mehr belastet werden wir wollen
den europäischen emissionshandel und das
brennstoff emissionshandels gesetz bhg
im sinne des eu programms fit for 50 5
über arbeiten wir setzen auf einen
steigenden co2 preis als wichtiges
instrument verbunden mit einem starken
sozialen ausgleich und werden dabei
insbesondere menschen mit geringeren
einkommen unterstützen was gut ist für
das klima wird günstiger was schlecht
ist
teurer
daher unterstützen wir die pläne der
europäischen kommission zur stärkung des
bestehenden emissionshandels und setzen
uns für eine ambitionierte reform
eingesetzen uns insbesondere auf
europäischer ebene für einen ets
mindestpreis sophie sowie die für die
schaffung eines zweiten emissionshandels
für die bereiche wärme und mobilität ets
2 1 dabei ist vorzusehen dass in den
jeweiligen eu mitgliedstaaten ein
sozialer ausgleich stattfindet in den
2030er jahren soll es ein einheitliches
eu
emissionshandelssystem über alle
sektoren geben dass belastungen nicht
einseitig zu lasten der verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher verschiebt
der preis im ets liegt derzeit bei um
die 60 euro die tonne nach allen nach
nach allen prognosen wird er strukturell
nicht unter dieses niveau fallen sondern
ihr steigen
sollte die entwicklung der nächsten
jahre anders verlaufen und die
europäische union sich nicht auf ein eps
mindestpreis verständigt haben werden
wir über die entsprechenden nationalen
maßnahmen entscheiden wie zum beispiel
zertifikat löschung oder mindestpreis
etc damit der co2 preis langfristig
nicht unter 60 euro die tonne fällt
das brennstoff emissionshandels gesetz
bhg
einschließlich der erfassten brennstoff
emissionen in der industrie industrielle
prozesswärme wollen wir auf seine
kompatibilität mit einem möglichen et 2
ots zwei überprüfen und gegebenenfalls
so anpassen dass ein möglichst
reibungsloser übergang
gewährleistet ist wir betrachten
energiepreise und co2 preise zusammen
angesichts des derzeitigen preisniveaus
durch nicht co2 preis getriebene
faktoren halten wir aus sozialen gründen
an bisherigen am bisherigen bhg preis
pfad fest wir werden ein vorschlag zur
ausgestaltung der marktphase nach 2026
machen um einen künftigen preisanstieg
zu kompensieren und die akzeptanz des
markt systems zu gewährleisten werden
wir einen sozialen
kompensationsmechanismus über die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage hinaus
entwickeln klima geld
klima und energie außenpolitik
wir stärken die
multilaterale zusammenarbeit im rahmen
der agenda
2030 und des pariser abkommens
und werden die deutschen umwelt klima
und energie kooperationen ausbauen
wir nutzen unter anderem die deutsche
die sieben präsidentschaft
2022 für eine initiative zur gründung
von klima partnerschaften sowie eines
für alle staaten offenen internationalen
klima clubs ziele sind unter anderem
klimaneutralität der massive ausbau
erneuerbarer energien und
deren infrastruktur die produktion von
wasserstoff wir streben ein globales
emissionshandelssystem an dass
mittelfristig zu einem einheitlichen co2
preis führt
wir werden unsere zusagen für den
deutschen anteil an den 100 milliarden
us-dollar der internationalen
klimafinanzierung im rahmen einer
kohärenten klima außenpolitik erfüllen
und perspektivisch erhöhen
unsere klima außenpolitik wollen wir
unter anderem mit dem klima kabinett
kohärenter und starker machen wir setzen
uns für eine reform des energiecharta
vertrages ein kater
[Musik]
transformation der wirtschaft
wir wollen die wettbewerbsfähigkeit des
wirtschaftsstandortes deutschland
als grundlage für nachhaltiges wachstum
wohlstand und hohe beschäftigung in
einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft erhöhen
wir werden unternehmen und beschäftigte
bestmöglich unterstützen innovation
fördern und neues zutrauen in
gründergeist innovation und
unternehmertum schaffen wir müssen die
klimakrise gemeinsam bewältigen darin
liegen auch große chancen für unser land
und den industriestandort deutschland
neue geschäftsmodelle und technologien
können klimaneutralen wohlstand und gute
arbeit schaffen wir sehen den weg zur
co2 neutralen welt als große chance für
den industriestandort deutschland neue
geschäftsmodelle und technologien können
klimaneutralen wohlstand und gute arbeit
schaffen wenn wir die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen für industrie und
mittelstand wie einen massiven ausbau in
der neue erneuerbare energien
wettbewerbsfähige energiepreise
versorgungssicherheit mit strom und
wärme sowie schnelle und unbürokratische
genehmigungsverfahren sicherstellen wir
wollen mehr privates kapital für
transformationsprojekte aktivieren dazu
prüfen wir auch welche beiträge
öffentlichen förderbanken zur
risikoabsicherung leisten können
im dialog mit wirtschaft gewerkschaften
und verbänden wollen wir eine allianz
für transformation schmieden
und in den ersten sechs monaten des
jahres 2022 stabile und verlässliche
rahmenbedingungen für die transformation
besprechen um die unternehmen bei ihren
investitionen auf dem weg zur
klimaneutralität zu unterstützen setzen
wir auf zielgerichtete instrumente dazu
legen wir unter anderem einen
transformationsphase bei der kfw auf
nutzen klimaschutz differenz verträge
fördern leuchtturmprojekte und schaffen
anreize für leitmärkte und für
klimaneutrale produkte wir werden auch
die kleinen mittleren unternehmen bei
ihrem weg zur klima technologischen
transformation begleiten und fördern wir
setzen uns für einen wirksamen karben
league hit schutz ein border jazzmen
mechanism freie zuteilung bei der
novellierung der europäischen klima
umwelt und energie beihilfe leitlinien
und andere regelungen werden wir darauf
achten dass die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
unternehmen gewahrt bleibt ein wichtige
rolle bei der transformation spielt die
energie und ressourceneffizienz das
heißt wie etwa industrie vergünstigungen
an die umsetzung wirtschaftliche
energieeffizienz maßnahmen zu knüpfen
oder produkt standards
weiterzuentwickeln
das gilt gleichermaßen
gleichermaßen auch für die energiewende
wir bekennen uns zur notwendigkeit auch
von technischen negativ emissionen und
werden eine langfrist strategie zum
umgang mit den etwa fünf prozent
unvermeidbaren rest emissionen
erarbeiten wir werden im dialog mit den
unternehmen lösungen suchen wie wir
betriebsgenehmigungen für
energieinfrastruktur
kraftwerke oder gasleitungen mit
fossilen brennstoffen rechtssicher so
erteilen können
dass der betrieb über das jahr 2045
hinaus nur mit nicht fossilen
brennstoffen fortgesetzt werden kann
ohne einen
investitionsstopp
fehlinvestition und
entschädigungsansprüche auszulösen
atom
in den internationalen bemühungen zur
erreichung der klimaneutralität bekennt
sich deutschland eindeutig zum ausbau
und zur nutzung der erneuerbaren
energien wir setzen uns auf
internationaler und europäischer ebene
dafür ein
dass die atomenergie für die von ihr
verursachten kosten selbst aufkommen wir
stellen uns der verantwortung für die
radioaktiven abfälle die
standortsuche für ein endlager
für hoch radioaktive abfälle soll
entsprechend der gesetzlich festgelegten
prinzipien
wissenschaftsbasierte
partizipativ
transparent sich selbst hinterfragen und
lernend fortgesetzt werden
genehmigte endlager
müssen zügig fertiggestellt und in
betrieb genommen werden
hierzu gehören auch die standortauswahl
und die errichtung des notwendigen
logistikzentrums wir werden uns für eine
abschaltung der grenznahen risiko
reaktoren einsetzen wir sprechen uns
dafür aus
kompetenzen in diesem bereich zu bündeln
viertens
respekt chancen und soziale sicherheit
in der modernen arbeitswelt
ein hohes beschäftigungsniveau und
gerechte entlohnung
sind grundlage für unseren wohlstand und
die finanzierung unserer sozialen
sicherung wir wollen jeder und jedem
eine möglichst sichere beschäftigung
biografie ermöglichen und die
beschäftigungsfähigkeit durch
qualifizierung und gesunde arbeit
erhalten
jede arbeit verdient respekt und
anerkennung
wir erhöhen den mindestlohn und schaffen
ein modernes arbeitsrecht dass
sicherheit und fair ausgehandelte
flexibilität ermöglicht setzen uns für
ein sozialstaat ein der die bürgerinnen
und bürger absichert aber auch dabei
unterstützt neue chancen im leben zu
ergreifen die rente muss verlässlich und
auskömmlich sein
darum sichern wir das rentenniveau und
ergänzen sie um kapitalgedeckte elemente
wir erneuern mit dem bürgergeld das
system der grundsicherung
alle menschen in deutschland sollen gut
versorgt und gepflegt werden in der
stadt und auf dem land unser ziel ist
eine moderne sektorenübergreifende
gesundheits und pflegepolitik die
pandemie hat uns die verletzlichkeit
unseres gesundheitswesens
vor augen geführt wir ziehen lehren
und sorgen für eine bedarfsgerechte
gesundheitsversorgung
sowie eine menschliche und qualitativ
hochwertige medizin und pflege
wohnen ist ein grundbedürfnis
wir werden dazu beitragen dass
ausreichend wohnraum geschaffen wird
und das bauen und wohnen der zukunft
bezahlbar
klimaneutral und barrierearm wird
wichtig für das wohnumfeld sind
lebendige öffentliche räume
arbeit wir wollen die moderne
arbeitswelt gestalten dabei berufliche
chancen ermöglichen sowie sicherheit und
flexibilität in einklang bringen
ausbildung
zur stärkung und zur stärkung und
modernisierung berufsbildender schulen
legen wir mit ländern kommunen und
relevanten akteuren einen pakt auf
mit den ländern bauen wir die
berufsorientierung und jugend
berufsorientierung flächendeckend aus
wir wollen eine ausbildungsgarantie die
allen jugendlichen einen zugang zu einer
voll qualifizierende berufsausbildung
ermöglicht stets vorrangig im betrieb
wir führen die allianz für ausbildung
fort die einstiegsqualifizierung die
assistierte ausbildung
ausbildungsbegleitende hilfen und
verbund ausbildungen bauen wir aus
eröffnen die hilfen für geflüchtete
wir begrüßen tariflich vereinbarter
ausgleichs in regionen mit erheblicher
unterversorgung an ausbildungsplätzen
initiieren wir bedarfsgerecht
außerbetriebliche ausbildungsangebote in
enger absprache mit den sozialpartnern
wir erhöhen die ausbildungs mobilität
für menschen in arbeitslosigkeit und
grundsicherung fördern wir voll
qualifizierende ausbildung bei der
beruflichen weiterbildung unabhängig von
ihrer dauer
vollzeitschulischer ausbildung
muss vergütet und frei von schulgeld
sein wir bringen eine
exzellenzinitiative
berufliche bildung auf den weg unter
anderem bauen wir innovex und öffnen die
begabtenförderungswerke des bundes für
die berufliche bildung gleichwertige
berufliche qualifikationen erkennen wir
für höhere karrierewege im öffentlichen
dienst an die ergebnisse des evaluations
auftrags zum dualen studium werden wir
zügig mit allen relevanten akteuren
beraten
weiterbildung in zeiten des digitalen
und demografischen wandels ist eine
gezielte nationale weiter
bildungsstrategie
wesentliche voraussetzung um unsere
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
ziele zu erreichen
wir verbessern möglichkeiten für
berufliche neuorientierung aus und
weiterbildung auch in teilzeit die
instrumente der bildungspolitik und der
aktiven arbeitsmarktpolitik stimmen wir
aufeinander ab zur unterstützung des
persönlich motivierten
lebensbegleitenden lernens
bauen wir das aufstiegs bafög aus
öffnen den unterhaltsbeitrag für
teilzeit fortbildungen fördern
weiterbildungen auch auf der gleichen
stufe des deutschen
qualifikationsrahmens
und auch für eine zweite
vollqualifizierende ausbildung erhöhen
die fördersätze und freibeträge
deutlich und schließen förder lücken zum
bafög
ziel ist das aufstiegs lehrgänge und
prüfungen mit angemessenen preisen
kostenfrei sind
mit dem lebenschancen bafög schaffen wir
ein neues instrument für die
selbstbestimmte weiterbildung auch
jenseits berufs und abschlussbezogene
qualifikation für alle
dazu schaffen wir eine einfache
möglichkeit zum bildungssparen in einem
freiraum konto menschen mit geringem
einkommen erhalten hierfür jährliche
zuschüsse mit einer bildungs teilzeit
nach österreichischem vorbild
bieten wir beschäftigten finanzielle
unterstützung für arbeitsmarkt bezogene
weiterbildung dies ermöglicht zum
beispiel das nachholen eines
berufsabschlusses oder eine berufliche
neuorientierung
voraussetzung ist eine vereinbarung
zwischen arbeitgeber und beschäftigten
die iba prüft die fördervoraussetzungen
die bundesagentur für arbeit ba kommt
der bundesagentur für arbeit kommt eine
stärkere rolle bei der qualifizierung
und dazugehöriger beratung zu
um alle an weiterbildung interessierten
und betriebe zu unterstützen
schaffen wir eine vernetzung der b a mit
den regionalen akteuren und einheitliche
anlaufstelle
dafür bauen wir die weiter für
weiterbildungs verbünde aus und
unterstützen den aufbau von
weiterbildungs agenturen die nationale
online weiterbildungsplattform und die
bildungsplattform werden
weiterentwickelt
verzahnt und verstetigt damit schaffen
wir einen übersichtlichen zugang zu
bildungs und beratungsangeboten sowie
förderinstrumenten mit einem als
kurzarbeitergeld angelehnten
qualifizierungs geld kann dpa
unternehmen im strukturwandel
ermöglichen ihre beschäftigten durch
qualifizierung in betrieb zu halten und
fachkräfte zu sichern
voraussetzung dafür sind
betriebsvereinbarungen gleichzeitig
setzen wir anreize für transformations-
tarifverträge auch das
transferkurzarbeitergeld
weiten wir aus und entwickeln die
instrumente des sgb 3 in
transfergesellschaften
für menschen in arbeitslosigkeit und in
der grundsicherung weiten wir die
eigenständige förderung von
grundkompetenzen haus
und stellen klar dass die vermittlung in
arbeit
keinen vorrang vor einer beruflichen aus
und weiterbildung hat die die
beschäftigungschancen stärkt bei
beruflicher qualifizierung erhalten sgb
2 und 3
leistungsberechtigte
ein zusätzliches monatliches
weiterbildungsgeld von 150 euro so dass
ein wirksamer anreiz zur weiterbildung
entsteht
nach einer weiterbildung soll mindestens
ein anspruch auf drei monate
arbeitslosengeld bestehen
arbeitszeit und arbeitsort
um auf die veränderungen in der
arbeitswelt zu reagieren und die wünsche
von arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmern und
unternehmen nach einer flexibleren
arbeitszeitgestaltung aufzugreifen
wollen wir gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeber dabei unterstützen flexible
arbeitszeitmodelle zu ermöglichen
wir halten am grundsatz des acht stunden
tages im arbeitszeitgesetz fest im
rahmen einer im jahr 2022 zu treffenden
befristeten regelung mit evaluations
klausel werden wir es ermöglichen dass
im rahmen von tarifverträgen
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen und in
einzuhaltenden fristen ihrer arbeitszeit
flexibler gestalten können außerdem
wollen wir eine begrenzte möglichkeit
zur abweichung von den derzeit
bestehenden regelungen des
arbeitszeitgesetzes hinsichtlich der
tageshöchst arbeitszeit schaffen wenn
tarifverträge oder
betriebsvereinbarungen aufgrund von
tarifverträgen dies vorsehen
experimentier räume
im dialog mit den sozialpartnern prüfen
wir welchen anpassungsbedarf wir an sitz
der rechtsprechung des europäischen
gerichtshofs zum arbeitsrecht sehen
dabei müssen flexible arbeitszeitmodelle
zum beispiel vertrauens arbeitszeit
weiterhin möglich sein
home office
grenzen wir als eine möglichkeit der
mobilen arbeit rechtlich von der
telearbeit und im geltungsbereich der
arbeitsstättenverordnung ab
arbeitsschutz gute arbeitsbedingungen
und das vorhandensein eines
betrieblichen arbeitsplatzes sind bei
mobiler arbeit wichtige voraussetzungen
dies erfordert informationen beratung
der beschäftigten
sowie deren angemessene unterstützung
durch ihre arbeitgeber
zur gesunden gestaltung des home office
erarbeiten wir im dialog mit allen
beteiligten sachgerechte und flexible
lösungen
coworking spaces sind eine gute
möglichkeit für mobile arbeit und die
stärkung ländlicher regionen
beschäftigte in geeigneten tätigkeiten
erhalten eine erörterung sun spruch über
mobiles arbeiten
und homeoffice arbeitgeber können dem
wunsch der beschäftigten nur dann
widersprechen wenn betriebliche belange
entgegenstehen das heißt dass eine
ablehnung nicht sachfremd oder
willkürlich sein darf für abweichende
tarifvertragliche und betriebliche
regelungen muss raum bleiben mobile
arbeit soll eu-weit unproblematisch
möglich sein
selbstständige
selbstständige sind wesentlicher teil
unserer gesellschaft und wirtschaft nach
der aktuellen reform des status
feststellung verfahrens führen wir im
lichte der erfahrungen
einen dialog mit selbstständigen und
ihren verbänden um dieses zu
beschleunigen und zu verbessern ziel ist
in der digitalen und agilen arbeitswelt
unbürokratische rechtssicherheit zu
schaffen
durch einen erleichterten zugang zur
freiwilligen arbeitslosenversicherung
unterstützen wir auch selbstständige
sowie gründerinnen und gründer wir
prüfen dabei ob und wie ein zugang ohne
vor versicherungszeit möglich ist wer
als geschäftsführer oder
geschäftsführerin in einer gmbh et
cetera tätig war und dafür beiträge
entrichtet hat
sollte anspruch auf arbeitslosengeld
haben die sonderregelung für unständig
beschäftigte in der
arbeitslosenversicherung
insbesondere für kulturschaffende
entfristen wir und prüfen
vereinfachungen und weiterentwicklung
zur unterstützung von solo
selbstständigen in der andauernden
corona pandemie führen wir die neustadt
hilfe im rahmen der überbrückungshilfe
3+ so lange wie benötigt ford
um auch bei zukünftigen schweren krisen
die zu nichts selbst verantworteten
erwerbs ausfällen führen
selbstständige auch bei der finanzierung
ihrer lebensunterhalts kosten schneller
und besser helfen zu können
treffen wir vorsorge für
steuerfinanzierte
wirtschaftshilfen
dabei werten wir die erfahrungen mit der
neue staat hilfe aus wir schaffen kein
neues regelsystem während der korona
pandemie hat sich die besondere
bedeutung der künstlersozialkasse für
die soziale absicherung von kreativen
und kulturschaffenden
bewährt diese wollen wir auch künftig
sicherstellen
mindestlohn
wir werden den gesetzlichen mindestlohn
in einer einmaligen anpassung auf zwölf
euro pro stunde erhöhen im anschluss
daran wird die unabhängige mindestlohn
kommission über die etwaigen weiteren
erhöhungs schritte befinden
wir unterstützen den vorschlag der eu
kommission für eine richtlinie über
angemessene armutsfeste mindestlöhne zur
stärkung des tarifsystems dabei setzen
wir uns unter achtung der europäischen
kompetenzordnung sowie unterschiedlicher
systeme und traditionen von
arbeitsbeziehungen in den
mitgliedstaaten bei den verhandlungen
für verbindliche mindeststandards
mindeststandards ein wie sie in
deutschland mit dem neuen
mindestlohngesetz nach beschluss gelten
werden
mini und midijobs
bei den mini und midijobs werden wir
verbesserungen vornehmen würden die eine
aufnahme versicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung erschweren wollen wir
abbauen
wir erhöhen die midi job grenz auf 1600
euro künftig orientiert sich die minijob
grenze an einer wochenarbeitszeit von
zehn stunden zumindest lohnbedingungen
sie wird dementsprechend mit anhebung
des mindestlohns auf
520 euro erhöht gleichzeitig werden wir
verhindern dass mini jobs als ersatz für
reguläre arbeitsverhältnisse missbraucht
oder zur teilzeit falle insbesondere für
frauen werden die einhaltung des
geltenden arbeitsrecht bei minijobs
werden wir stark kontrollieren
[Applaus]
haushaltsnahe dienstleistungen
durch die förderung haushaltsnaher
dienstleistungen unterstützen wir die
vereinbarung von familie und beruf die
erwerbsbeteiligung von ehe und
lebenspartner und schaffen gleichzeitig
mehr sozialversicherte arbeitsplätze die
inanspruchnahme familien und alltags
unterstützende dienstleistungen
erleichtern wir durch einen zulagen und
gutscheinsystem und die möglichkeit für
flankierende steuerfreier arbeitgeber
zuschüsse
die zulagen und die bestehende
steuerliche förderung werden verrechnet
sie dient der förderung
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung im haushalt profitieren
sollen zunächst alleinerziehende
familien mit kindern und zu pflegenden
angehörigen schrittweise alle haushalte
befristungen damit der öffentliche
dienst als arbeitgeber mit gutem
beispiel vorangeht schaffen wir die nur
dort bestehende möglichkeit der
haushalts befristung ab
beim bund als arbeitgeber
reduzieren wir die sachgrundlose
befristung schritt für schritt um ketten
befristungen zu vermeiden
begrenzen wir mit sachgrund befristete
arbeitsverträge beim selben arbeitgeber
auf sechs jahren nur in engen begrenzten
ausnahmen ist ein überschreiten dieser
höchstdauer möglich
arbeitnehmerüberlassung und
arbeitskräfte mobilität
beim arbeitnehmerüberlassungsgesetz
überprüfen wir im falle einer
europäischen rechtsprechung ob und
welche gesetzlichen änderungen unter
berücksichtigung der gesetzes
evaluierung vorzunehmen sind wir
verbessern den schutz von beschäftigten
bei grenzüberschreitenden entsendungen
und bauen bürokratische hürden ab für
saison beschäftigte sorgen wir für den
vollen krankenversicherungsschutz ab dem
ersten tag wir stärken fähre mobilität
und klären beschäftigte so besser über
ihre rechte auf wie ratifizieren das
übereinkommen nummer 184 der
internationalen arbeitsorganisation ilo
über den arbeitsschutz in der
landwirtschaft
werkverträge und arbeitnehmerüberlassung
sind notwendigen instrumente
strukturelle und systemische verstohlen
verstöße gegen arbeitsrecht und
arbeitsschutz verhindern wir durch
effektivere rechtsdurchsetzung so sagen
wir auch für mehr sicherheit bei arbeit
auf abruf die krisen regelungen beim
kurzarbeitergeld
werden wir nach der korona pandemie
evaluieren insbesondere mit blick auf
menschen mit geringem einkommen
tarifautonomie wir wollen die
tarifautonomie die tarifpartner und die
tarifbindung stärken damit faire löhne
in deutschland bezahlt werden dies
befördert auch die nötige
lohnangleichung zwischen ost und west
zur stärkung der tarifbindung wird die
öffentliche auftragsvergabe des bundes
an die einhaltung eines repräsentativen
tarifvertrages der jeweiligen branche
gebunden wobei die vergabe auf einer
einfachen unbürokratischen erklärung
beruht betriebs ausgliederung bei
identität des bisherigen eigentümers zum
zwecke der tarifflucht werden wir
verhindern indem wir die fortgeltung des
geltenden tarifvertrags sicherstellen
unangetastet bleibt § 1 und 3 613 a bgb
rechte und pflichten beim